so Michael Knowles was speaking uh where
was the University of Pittsburgh I
believe pit last night pit last night
when far leftists burned him in effigy
set fires outside obviously in addition
to the Effigy and through an explosive
which caused the building to get locked
down and it's it's fairly par for the
course we've seen with far left
extremism but uh with all that happening
I'd have to wonder how would you define
burning something with the intent to
intimidate because we have another story
where the guys who March in
Charlottesville with tiki torches are
being criminally indicted for marching
with tiki torches now look I don't think
anyone in this room likes go like likes
those guys in fact I'm assuming most of
you watching probably don't like those
guys either but they're allowed their
free speech if they want to March around
chanting or whatever okay fine the left
can do it I don't like them but they're
allowed to do it we can clearly see how
the how the government is being
weaponized against certain people and
not against others but I think to put it
um to to condense the thought the left
has weaponized the government against
anyone it doesn't like so while there
may be some people we don't like either
they're just going after their political
enemies so we'll talk about that but we
also got more news Washington and
Colorado are now becoming I guess you'd
call them child sex change tourism
States Washington has advanced a bill
where they will not tell parents about
the whereabouts of children who run away
to seek sex changes and in Colorado
they're going to give children puberty
blockers if even if their parents said
no and they fled to that state so um man
these are wild times plus we have this a
very funny viral video a funny sad by
the way of John fetterman's return to
the Senate and uh oh man I just at what
point does anybody intervene to stop
this just everything just all of it so
we got a lot to talk about before we do
my friends head over to castbrew.com and
pick up your pre-order of our cast Brew
Coffee rise with Roberto Jr breakfast
blend Appalachian nights robust dark
blend and also Colombian and French
roast are available these are the first
roasts we have available for pre-order
it will ship by May 5th because we're
opening up a coffee shop so these are
our first line of products that are
going to be readily ready and available
before the shop itself actually opens
and then hopefully in a year or two we
have like 10 different shops get the
snowball rolling down the hill it's a
bit ambitious maybe in five years we got
50 to 100 maybe in 10 years there's 10
000 of these things and then uh you know
anti-wok corporations can start growing
with your support also don't forget to
head over to timcast.com click that join
us button become a member and you can
watch the members only uncensored show
which will be live on the front page of
timcast.com at about 10 10 pm eastern
time and if you've been a member for at
least six months or you sign up at the
25 per month level you can submit
questions and even call into the show to
talk with us and our guests it's the
most fun part of the night in my opinion
so smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and share the show right
now take that URL post it wherever you
can if you really do like us that's the
best way to help joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is the
man himself Michael Knowles it's good to
be with you and I was burned in effigy
last night but I'll tell you what I
think I got the last laugh because Tim
I'm still alive they did not succeed
they did however after we were escorted
out of the debate Hall following the
debate they locked the room down for
over an hour so no one in the hall was
able to leave because the libs were
rioting so much outside and then I kid
you not I was looking up I said I gotta
find some information about what's going
on out there and there was a Pitt
student who said
we had a peaceful protest mostly
peaceful well let's uh we'll uh we'll
talk about that for those that don't
know you uh who are you what do you do I
am a genocidal fascist according to CNN
and uh literally did CNN actually say
that no it was uh Daily Beast and
rolling stone called me genocidal wow
Huffington Post I may have called me
genocidal too all because of my terrible
position that uh boys and girls are
different you know I brought you
chocolate bars I was I was gonna say too
um we we finally got some of this the uh
Jeremy's chocolate she her he him
um I ate the nuts they were delicious
yeah uh uh he hims nuts that's the one I
chose he's big on nuts what do you mean
do you think it was gay to eat the nuts
what do you mean I don't I mean you want
you want to eat the nuts uh in every day
and and you wanted the one without nuts
right Mary I mean I'll suck the
chocolate off him first
I'm all for standards and norms and
everything but I will tell you the one
with nuts is better I yeah so you you
know we had four I tried one I decided
to try the the he him nuts bar just
because I figured it's probably gonna
have more protein flavor to it I mean
well protein too I just figured the she
her is probably a little you know
plane right it's just chocolate but you
know chocolate's good so we'll crack
this open a little bit so of course Mary
Morgan's hanging out hello everyone it's
me Mary I guess it's been a minute since
I've been on IRL except for Austin I
don't know if that counts yeah because
it was just Alex streaming the whole
time but I'm on pop culture crisis right
here at timcast nice to be here hello
Michael great to see you Ian Crossing if
you don't know but uh did you feel like
dark voodoo magic when they were burning
your Refugee I didn't I I actually
thought it was all very funny especially
I mean we had basically the hundred
first Airborne there so I don't know
these guys they could have had whatever
explosives they wanted we take security
very seriously I was also staying at a
haunted hotel and so I didn't let's
let's save it you got a spiritual Shield
man I like it I'm I'm meeting some of
this she heard it's very good Jeremy
you've got a great font man nice work
good fun we got surge pressing the
buttons yo what's up y'all uh I'm ready
to start when you guys are all right
let's just jump into the story
explosion at University of Pittsburgh
transgender debate causes safety
emergency as protesters Yellen chant one
protester set fire to a cardboard cutout
with a conservative commentator's face
on it according to the Pittsburgh Post
Gazette do they have the burning and
Effigy in this article
they have the protests they don't they
don't but uh yes Michael so you are
going to be debating uh at the
University on transgender transgender
issues I guess the the other and the
professor backed out and then far left
extremists set fire set fires and burned
you an effigy this entire debate got
more absurd by the day because I was
invited by isi the Intercollegiate
Studies Institute
to debate this professor uh Donald
McCloskey who now goes by Deirdre he has
transitioned
this is a very respected Professor this
guy is three degrees from Harvard he's
got half a dozen honorary doctors he's
got two dozen academic Publications
I am but a lowly podcaster I have no
particularly Advanced degree I've
written two books only one of them has
words in it okay the professor should
have been down to debate the professor
didn't like me from the beginning
especially because of my seat back
speech called me a fascist called me an
anti-jesus Catholic what I guess he's
Episcopalian or something I really don't
need to be lectured on theology by
Episcopalian but but yeah yeah he he
identifies that way at least but he he
said even though Knowles is terrible
it's important that we debate these
issues and he kept sort of insulting my
intelligence we had a pre-debate call
just a few weeks ago in which he
reiterated his desire to debate and then
a week or so before the debate he pulls
out and he pulled out because he's
intelligent and I think he realized that
not even a guy with three Harvard
degrees and a whole bunch of honorary
doctorates could defend this
indefensible idea I think he also may
have pulled out because he realized that
I'm not just a provocateur bomb thrower
like the literal bomb throwers that were
outside of the building that he I think
he just realized I'm kind of relatively
polite and we were just going to debate
these issues he couldn't do it and so
Brad Palumbo the libertarian leaning uh
I guess he would call himself a
conservative but he's a very left on
LGBT issues he filled in and I give him
a lot of credit for Pinch hitting and
allowing this debate to go on but but
even with Brad who's relatively moderate
on these issues relatively to today
where we're chopping off little kids
genitals uh the the protesters were just
absolutely nuts and uh and they did
everything they could to shut it down
they tried to burn me an effigy they did
bring it well I guess they did burn me
an effigy but here I am baby I'm not
burned at all what was it you said
before that angered these people that
with transgenderism needed to be
eradicated the concept of trans that's
right I don't I probably haven't been on
the show since the CPAC speech yeah I
said I've now memorized this quote
because it's come up in the news so much
for the good of society and especially
for the good of the poor people who've
Fallen prey to this confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life the whole Preposterous
ideology at every level so how do you
but let's let's clarify that you you
were literally talking about gender
ideology you weren't talking about
people of course so I said it's an ism
first of all refers to a set of beliefs
and then lest there be any confusion I
clarified in the parenthetical
immediately I said it's a Preposterous
ideology I said for the good of the
people who have this confusion so
presumably I don't want to murder these
people there was no way to misinterpret
what I said which is why the left-wing
media just changed my words so The Daily
Beast Rolling Stone they defamed me they
they admitted they defamed me because
they ultimately changed the headlines
you know fly gets halfway around the
world before the truth catches it we
have the the video of Michael knows oh
wow actually from Tim cast news
um right out of his neck and chest it's
neck and chest we'll say it is an effigy
and so I just I just asked you right
right uh I just look at this kind of
stuff and I wonder is the intention here
to intimidate because the end I mean the
answer is simply put yes or black magic
yeah who knows black magic also to
intimidate my soul but you're you're
using a very specific word there Tim why
would you why would you use that word
because we got a story earlier that uh
in Charlottesville they they're
indicting the tiki torch Marchers and uh
they say it's because they burned
something with the intent to intimidate
and it's like dude come on we know what
that bill is supposed to be the law is
supposed to be about supposed to be
about like someone putting a cross in
your yard and sitting on a fire not
walking down the sidewalk setting a
cigarette yeah exactly saying dumb
things holding it a tiki torch which
keeps mosquitoes away and and and here's
the thing right I I I hold that group in
a similar disdain to as I hold these
these groups both are out of their Free
Speech but as you see law enforcement
goes in Only One Direction I mean it's
kind of a weird thing because
they're identitarians the same as the
white nationalists but for Like A
different race so I actually don't view
their ideologies as different
for the most part you know that's kind
of weird well nobody is intimidated by
either these people burning you an
effigy because they look ridiculous and
nobody was intimidated realistically by
the tiki torch Marchers in
Charlottesville wearing white polo
shirts
when they were throwing respectful when
they were throwing explosives at the
wall that I didn't feel worried because
again we take security very seriously
but that is a somewhat intimidating
action when they're throwing explosives
persuasion I would definitely call it
intimidation this is what I'm tired of
I'm tired of the the attempt by the
so-called moderate individuals I
consider myself fairly moderate right
but I've heard this over and over again
when I was in Berkeley someone someone
took uh I think was an M80 and threw it
in the air and it landed next to an old
woman and exploded and she fell down and
I said someone just through an explosive
at this old lady and they're oh come on
it's a firecracker and then it blows
them into the okay
not playing that game yeah it's an
explosive did it explode it explode
m80s are not like little poppers can
take your fingers off yeah take your
whole hand off and so this woman like
Falls over
they also take these mortar shells which
are like the size of maybe tennis balls
maybe a little bit smaller and when they
explode they spray like everyone's seen
fireworks when they go up in the air and
then it blossoms yeah imagine that on
the ground those are explosives and you
get these people on first of all the
left will of course call them
firecrackers because they want to
minimize the language but then you'll
get people online being like look I
don't look antifa but those are just
flowers no explosives and it's like okay
see what happens one of those goes off
next to your head right they're both
your fireworks and explosives yeah it's
fireworks are explosives of course but
but just to clarify I'll call it a
firework if you put it in a tube and it
launches into the air and it looks
pretty I'll call an explosive when
you're trying to kill people with it
yeah like a knife isn't a murder tool
unless you kill somebody with it yeah
like exactly it's if if if I went to a
steakhouse this past weekend and I love
it when they walk up and they say your
knife sir and you get to pick one you
ever see I've ever had that happen it's
like the second time in my life and I'm
like oh take this one he's not handing
me a murder weapon he's handing me a
utensil however if someone one took that
and killed somebody it would then be in
a bag labeled to murder weapon
difference so Michael I gotta ask how do
you based on this this quote that kind
of set this all In Motion about
eradicating transgenders and why those
two words are pretty extreme to have
near each other but how do you balance
that with transgender people in your
love or care for people that happen to
be going through what they're going
through well there is no such
ontological category as transgender
people that there are people who are
confused about their sex but the whole
point is that there is no such thing as
a man who is secretly a woman that's
that's a false anthropology and this is
why the libs had to lie about what I
said and change my words and throw
explosives at me and burn me an effigy
because they have no answer to that
because we all know that that's true we
all know that these men are not actually
women and we're just lying to them to
varying degrees and this was I think the
weakest part of Brad Palumbo's argument
last night at Pitt was he tried to have
a moderate position which is okay these
men are not actually women but we should
treat them as women in the bathrooms but
not on the sports teams and we should do
it to the 19 year olds but not the 17
year olds and it it just is so arbitrary
either men can really be women or they
can and and that was that was why the
left reacted so much to my speech
because the libs thought that they had
won on the issue of transgenderism no
one took this thing seriously 10 years
ago now it is enshrined in our law and
they thought that they won and they
thought that the debate over
transgenderism was now going to be
should we trans the seven year olds or
should we wait till they turn eight and
in my speech I said no guys there's no
uncertain issues there's a middle ground
like taxes we can come to a middle
agreement on immigration what's the
right number of immigrants
either women have bathrooms or they
don't have bathrooms the minute you let
a man into the woman's bathroom the
women lose their bathroom so we gotta we
gotta pick one but I think there is a
moderate solution to that it just single
single room bathrooms right you could
abolish women's bathrooms altogether but
some women might might say you know the
issue isn't that we don't have enough
bathrooms out there because this is the
other the other people they'll say well
we just need another sports team for the
transgenders but it's going to be we
obviously we'll need two more sports
teams one for the female to male
transgenders and one for the male to
feel so how many how many times I just
agree a little bit I mean I don't care
we make whatever League you want you can
make uh if they made a league where it's
like a basketball team with five players
and one of them has to be a woman and
we'll call it the uh the the four the
one in four teams League I don't care
make up whatever League you want the
idea for me uh I'll go back to the
bathroom thing too I'm at the airport
this past weekend and they have men's
room women's room and then all gender in
the middle guess which bathroom I used
all gender it's a big price private room
I'm like this is fantastic I can take my
coat off I can hang it up I get like a
big mirror to myself watchman's I I
think it's fantastic this used to be
called family bath that's right they
just changed the label fair point though
there's always a huge line coming out of
the women's bathroom so taking that
bathroom away and giving them a single
room is probably gonna make things
probably gonna have to just turn the
whole airport into a bunch of individual
single small bathrooms my issue is uh
when it comes to female sports is that
we did not create women's leagues
because sometimes people wear dresses we
created women's leagues because
biological females have different
physical characteristics and want to
compete amongst themselves without men
yeah so all of a sudden now the debate
becomes well is a trans woman a woman
then they can compete on the wins team
but it's like no no hold on if you're
making the argument that woman just
refers to social constructs let me just
remind you we did not create the WNBA
because sometimes people wear dresses
real quick because the women playing
basketball in the WNBA are wearing the
same jerseys that guys wear like the
social constructs don't play so
important I think to to say like a boy
is a boy and if he becomes a trans girl
or trans woman he's still a boy that is
a trans woman like you never stop being
a boy you never stop being a human
you're still a human that identifies as
a carrot or whatever or a man that
identifies as a woman but it's still a
man and a trans woman together you can
be both but right but you're right Ian
and the issue is they they reject that I
don't know I've never really had a deep
conversation with someone there isn't
one this is the problem with it is every
time that I've tried to engage in a
conversation with a serious person I'm
not just talking about some clout
chasing YouTubers or whatever I'm
talking I wanted the most serious
pro-trans person there was I got the
best Professor for it and he pulled out
of the debate isi then invited like a
dozen people who are big in the
transgender movement none of them would
because they can't debate it but here's
the correct unit it is I think
I've thought about these issues gun
control assault weapons what is a woman
things like that and I feel like I've
done a better job articulating what
their position should be of course the
issue is and you could probably do the
same you could better articulate an
argument on their behalf but if you're
being consistent you're being logical
and honest you arrive more in a position
where we are you say okay I can't make
those arguments well there's just no way
to make it work because they make a lot
of mutually contradictory arguments on
the one hand they'll say well
transgenderism is when your true self
doesn't align with your body but but so
I guess your soul is female but your
body's man I believe in Souls but but
they also don't believe in Souls so then
they'll make a materialist argument
they'll say okay well no it's actually
your body is male but your brain is
female which first of all is based on
just complete bunk science and they're
interesting they're interesting ways to
debunk the methodological issues in
those in those studies but I think that
was formally debunked though to be
honest there was a yeah I remember uh
there was a big issue with
trans-racialism
um like seven years ago and people were
we're trying to use this idea that a
brain could be male or female and the
body could be different as the
explanation and then something happened
where an academic created a transracial
argument saying that individuals who
have let's say a person is like 2.7
percent Asian and they present white
they may have within their minds that
they're actually Asians and the left
went and lost it because now Earth whoa
no white people aren't you can't do that
and so that kind of broke the whole life
the other reason the brain studies are
crazy is one men and women's Brains are
a little bit different but the problem
is the studies when they're looking at
the brains they're looking at people
generally who have been on these
cross-sex hormones forever so you can't
know if the hormones themselves are
changing the brain makeup also the way
in which the brains are a little bit
different say the brain of a trans woman
from a man uh the the difference does
not make the brain look like a female
brain it makes it look like a little bit
different entirely and so there are all
sorts of problems with that but but even
then the problem with their argument is
your brain is part of your body they're
just so you're saying part of my body is
male but the other part is female but it
doesn't actually show up on the skin it
just doesn't make sense here's what
confused me with all of it the question
what is a woman
I can easily answer the question for the
left but they can't answer their own
question I don't quite understand what
so what is the what would you think the
leftist definition of woman is a human
who identifies as an adult human female
because and and it wasn't hard for me to
think that like they said female is sex
and woman is social construct and I said
okay so if someone's a woman they're
identifying as a biological female but
not but not right how come not one
leftist has ever said that sentence
that's it's a great point because it it
remains kind of circular but in a
Charming way this is why I I don't even
really love the right it's the social
construct argument yeah attached to
biology right but I I don't even just
love the biological argument because I
sort of think it partakes of the Same
Soul denying scientism that got us in
this mess in the first place you know if
the answer to what is a woman is 2x
chromosomes in a womb I think well you
know I think there's more to it than
that man maybe sugar spice and
everything nice I a woman is much more
than her body but a woman is at the very
least her body and it's not like this is
a brand new question that cropped up we
do have thousands and thousands of years
of very sophisticated thinking on what
constitutes a man what constitutes a
woman but the moment you try to engage
in that conversation the transgenderists
run away because there there is no way
to defend it the big divide I see here
is not between the men and women and the
trans and the whatever the opposite of
trans is it's between people who view
human Humanity as being made up of
intellect and will got an intellect so I
can perceive the truth and I've got a
will so I can act on it and the people
on the left who say forget that
intellect stuff it's all about the will
well I think I'm thinking that this is
where I keep going to I think what's
happening is there's the the Catholic
the the Christian conservative that says
that a spirit impregnated Jesus's mother
that somehow and it's like I'm into
reality so if a guy's gonna say a boy is
a girl I'm into reality a boy is a boy
and Spirits do not impregnate women and
you need male sperm yeah well no I mean
the the Virgin birth did happen and the
incarnations the pivot of history but
you're right one of those things is
Fantastical is the miracle that that uh
directs the entire course of history
what's happening is yeah people that are
identifying as a woman that as a man is
like well they say that ghosts can
impregnate people so yeah
the god itself categories of male and
female altogether they're denying that
there are natural laws Miracles are just
things that happen that deviate from the
natural laws seemingly for Supernatural
reasons but you've got to admit but God
could impregnate a woman's body is
mythical that's Fantastical why I I I I
think that you're in two separate
categories and you're conflating these
things I'm trying to find a solution
between the magical thinking but they're
not explaining to you God is omnipotent
that God is the Creator God is outside
of time and space and the Mystery of the
Incarnation is that God the Divine logic
of the universe the logos takes on human
flesh and dwells Among Us and uh this is
the pivot of history now the reason this
is not magical thinking is God being
defined as the maximally great being as
omnipotent can do what he Wills
especially as he is logic itself uh a
little boy is not God a little boy is
not omnipotent and or a 25 year old man
for that matter and so when a 25 year
old man says I'm actually a woman and
comes up with some cockamami
explanations to why that is that can't
make sense now I'm not I'm not insisting
that you believe in God but I I am
pointing out that if you if you
acknowledge that some things are better
than other things and that an
intelligible World probably implies an
intelligence that created the world
that's outside of time and space then
the existence of Miracles is not
something that's crazy or unbelievable
that would not naturally follow I'll
just address it for you I Ian if a boy
was witnessed by uh let's say let's just
say a young man 20 years old
six foot tall walked into a a town
center walked into Columbus Circle in in
New York City and ever and hundreds of
people gathered around and then he went
something strange is happening and then
transformed into a woman that's a
miracle right yeah but that's that's
never that's impossibility and that that
exactly is the difference between your
argument when someone comes out and says
that they can undergo surgery and
they're now a woman they're not they're
a man I agree with that but I also I
believe in God all right so hold on the
difference is the left is not making the
argument that a man magically
transformed by power of God into a woman
they're arguing that they can surgically
change their bodies or medically and
that makes them the same as someone who
was born they're arguing that it's not
Supernatural that it's actually just a
natural fact of the world I feel like
the argument is they're saying green is
red when I want it to be red and I'm
saying well let's just be real green is
green red is red and you're right the
difference between that and say like
faith-based miracle-believing they're
just different categories I don't know I
don't think so I mean they're definitely
different categories but different ways
of kind of taking leaps of assumption
about things that I think are patently
impossible I I've seen I've never seen
an inkling of evidence that is that God
could impregnate a human body well I
that you're talking about faith versus
denying it's also I just think it's also
faith transgenderism is Faith it's it
but look I can only I can only say it
like one more time it's not the same
thing it's not the same but I'm trying
to find a through line for in a solution
but it's not I think you're attaching
two things that don't come together
you're mesmerized by a a central miracle
in the history of the world the pivot of
history but are you saying let's put
that aside for a moment are you saying
that no Miracles can happen you think
the idea of Miracles itself is is uh
impossible well Miracle how would you
define Miracle a uh suspension of the
natural laws in a way that is improbable
and fantastic that is possible because
we're still learning what the natural
laws are as we've gained
but I've never seen any of them
let me try it this way uh is it possible
we live in a simulation yeah could the
person in control the simulation alter
the code on a whim to say impregnate a
woman yeah but you got to save the
possibility of being in a simulation is
near zero it's actually closer to one if
you believe the point you know 100
million trillion but but let's not
deviate it let's assume that we're in a
simulation it's possible that's a bet
not a good assumption because that is a
very unlikely you're just trying to
avoid answers any evidence but okay go
for it yeah didn't you you already
granted the possibility it is um
simulation theory is is possible uh
there are many smart thinkers uh the
easiest one is Elon Musk that's so
famous who believe that if it is
possible to create a universe to
simulate a universe based on our current
here's here's the idea based on our
current level of Technology we have
created such vast virtual worlds in 30
years with the Advent of this technology
it is likely that in another 30 years
we'll be able to create things
indistinguishable from reality can
considering where deep fakes are at
already yeah we're only probably 10
years away from being able to render on
the Fly universes
so if assuming that most 10 years most I
mean yeah that might be a little long
yeah with deep fakes already the point
where they can make Joe Rogan say
whatever they want him to say and even
show his him there was a commercial of
Joe Rogan selling a product because they
just type into computer pressed enter
and it rendered a video now imagine they
had to do the exact same thing but using
3D modeling like
um Unity or something Unreal Engine or
something like that it would not we're
only a few years away from that so this
is the argument about stimulism that's
if it is possible for us to do in only a
few years there is a strong likelihood
we actually exist in such a universe but
I don't want to debate too far my point
is just that I don't like that analogy
by the way I don't like that that belief
that if we might do it in the future if
it's likely that we'll do in the future
that it already happened doesn't make
sense but you already granted the point
Ian right that Miracles are possible but
possible is a strange word because point
zero trillionth of a percent possible
but you're just making up but also the
words Miracles you know I gotta agree
you're making up that stuff you might
see a crack of lightning that looks like
a guy's face a miracle is a supernatural
event and not a natural event but a
supernatural but but yeah and you are
making up that probability that's not it
oh no absolutely none of us can quantify
simply put there is a difference okay
I'll put it this way you make a video
game you as the programmer can decide
you're playing The Sims you can
literally lift the person up put them in
a bathroom and get rid of the door you
can do that as the person in control of
this year I'll Grant you this there
might be a technology in the future
where you can vibrate a woman's womb
it's not that you're you're completely
misunderstood always get to the
vibrations when I'm when I'm programming
a video game I can just right click
insert object and manifest a goblin
there's no point at which I have to find
a person and then draw on him and make
him no like when you're programming
something you can just put it there when
you're playing Fallout you want to build
a treehouse you click a button boom The
Treehouse appears there's a difference
between you being a programmer who can
make something happen and in the game a
character deciding they are not what you
made them there there's there's a it's a
very good analogy yeah if the power goes
out good luck convincing anyone we're in
a simulation like we're we're like
fantasizing about some ridiculous
possibility because we have electricity
is is that I'm not trying to fantasize
I'm trying to point out that arguing
someone who is biologically male who's
who you can observe their DNA under an
electron microscope and see they have X
and Y chromosomes coming out and saying
actually after the surgery they're now
female because this is one component of
this you're not I was at a uh I I often
mention I'm saying at poker tables
because that tends to be what I'm doing
on the weekends there's a dealer and
someone brought up on the TV they were
having a discussion about men and female
sports and the dealer said something
like it was kind of obvious the dealer
was not taking kindly to all of these 30
to 40 year old men who are not happy
with this they were grumbling about it
and then I said something like uh the
dealer said transgender females and I
said no no you mean transgender males a
transgender female is a trans man and a
transgender male is a trans woman and he
was like no wait what no he got upset
about it the point is
if someone is female
and they are transgender they are they
are they have a womb they have breasts
but they want to exhibit the
characteristics of a male that is a
trans man what's happened now is the
left is conflating they are saying
female and and woman mean the same thing
now so you'll often hear people say
transgender female to refer to a
biological male Who Wants To Be A a
woman right they're confusing the
language it was it has to be confused
because there's no argument for it and
to your point Ian you're saying well I
don't like magical thinking on the left
so I don't want magical thinking on the
right either but the difference here is
there are many good Arguments for the
existence of God and then we can get
into miracles from the existence of God
but there are many good or I could give
you a five right now I could probably
give you ten right now and there are no
good Arguments for transgenderism and
and so this is why we have theology this
is why we've had very wise men for
thousands of years discussing this in a
recent way and this is why not even a
esteemed scholar on transgender and
we'll show up to debate this issue so I
think if we just follow logic
you you might choose not to believe in
the Miracles you might choose not to
believe in God even but there's a
logical argument for that there is no
logical life God is logical at this
state with quantum physics and the
ability to see Cosmic microwave
background radiation it looks like a
neural pattern and that's that's what
Michael's saying about logos in the
embodia yeah it is it seems like
waveformer waves
I want a sentient waveform doesn't
necessarily mean that these Miracles
were real just because someone told me
that I I but I I just want to I'll make
one more point we're gonna move to
another story oh my gosh let's talk
about this all night no it's just
because you're saying the same thing
over and over it's important because I
think the people the transgender
Community is not taking your stuff
seriously because of that kind of just
accept it but but you're no look I read
a book when I was 19 years old that um I
would say made me believe in God I've
talked told the stories about the
conversations I've had with people who
are religious when I view myself as an
atheist and the book that I actually
read was about quantum physics and uh uh
putting electrons through conductors and
then trapping them to simulate elements
in and things of that nature and the
prospect that we could create
one-dimensional sheets of an element
that by and then by altering the amount
of electrons we push through the
conductors we could change the elemental
properties and things like that I
started reading that stuff and then it
made me start to think about the
universe think about simulation Theory
and logic and then I was like oh wow
like I'm starting to see a bigger
picture here understanding that there is
like we are we are in some kind of
logical system the universe uh it's hard
to quantify to be completely honest well
it's the very facts that you're speaking
in a way that is intelligible to me
presupposes that there is such a thing
as logic outside of ourselves and it
implies an intelligent career I want to
make sure I get this one before they try
and take a clip my point is humans write
math we then create equations and solve
problems and humans have a degree of
understanding of math that is not a
human creation it is humans mapping the
logic of the universe meaning the logic
of the universe exists to a massive
degree well beyond our comprehension and
we have a tiny little flashlight that
we're pointing in the dark and writing
down what we see it's possible that
after billions of years humans create
this big huge uh Quantum Blackboard
showing all of the code that we would
describe of the universe and that is the
logic or whatever you describe it as but
we can only see a tiny piece of it it's
real it exists and we're mapping it out
within the confines of that to say
something like yes this thing is
discernably wood it's a it's a word we
use to describe this carbon structure
I've decided to smoke
that that doesn't do anything you can't
and here's another example two plus two
equals five they say well no it doesn't
and I've I it's funny because when I was
a teenager I actually got into an
argument with a friend of mine who was
in high school and they were teaching
this back then
I I she she told me one plus one does
not equal two that's a social construct
and I said what are you talking about no
it isn't and I was like I have a pen in
this hand I grabbed pants off her table
I was like here's a pen here's a pen I
have one pen here one pen here there's
two pens in my hand there will never be
a circumstance where that is three pens
yeah and then you're like you don't
understand and I was like no I don't
think you understand but I don't wanna I
don't want to go in circles on that I do
want to move on to the next story
because uh we have this well let's we'll
we'll maybe come back in the members
only stuff and get more more deep yeah I
want to solve it and Sheamus is back on
Sundays music's the other way music's
the proactive way that I think brings us
together this talking about the literal
Logics of what we're doing wrong is
another harder though music's very
logical I always didn't get into that in
that member block and there's there's
correlation to like the human heartbeat
and blood flow and the vibrations and
stuff but let's uh let's read the story
from the post Malone I know this one's
interesting wired writer suspended from
Twitter after using platform to solicit
and receive Matt Walsh's hacked
materials Dell Cameron said prove me
wrong kids send Matt Walsh DMS to and
then post did his email address
they say on Wednesday wired senior
reporter Del Cameron was permanently
suspended from Twitter permanently after
he asked for an obtained hacked
materials from Matt Walsh's Twitter
account quote spoke with the hacker who
says he compromised Matt Walsh's account
and was able to supply some convincing
proof they'd gained access to his
personal email account story to come our
story TK
I mean that means I think that means
coming soon a tweet just after midnight
read in a post to Mastodon Cameron
stated they just got permanently
suspended for publishing this story
linking to an article he wrote titled
the hacker who hijacked Matt Walsh's
Twitter was just bored another post
revealed that Cameron was suspended from
Twitter for violations of the social
media's policies against the
distribution of hacked materials the
story alleges that the hacker provided
screenshots of an apparent copy of Matt
Walsh's W-2 tax form which lists his
employer as bent key Services LLC the
publisher of the daily wire a direct
message on Twitter from Shapiro from
2017 emails between Walsh and the
conservative commentator Crowder host of
Lottery Crowders podcast dated March
14th Etc I don't want to go through all
that because I don't want to actually
reveal any of that private information
but this just goes to show in my opinion
many of these corporate journalists
they're working in collusion with in
tandem with the people who are sending
threats who are intimidating
there was a story of I think it was a
Conde Nast executive who was um
he was uh he was gay and I think he was
trying to have some kind of gay hookup I
can't remember the exact story but a
blackmailer got access to the
information and said if you don't give
me money I will give this to journalists
and I think it was Gawker I could be
wrong but the journalists were like we
would love to publish this and and
basically collude with a blackmailer
what Del Cameron is doing here this
wired reporter is basically saying we
will be the the information laundering
service for those that want to destroy
your life and harass and intimidate and
cause you harm
so Matt Walsh who clearly has
ideological enemies will seek out the
the enemies will seek out any means by
which they can cause damage to him and
this is quote unquote journalists the
great irony of this is the journals who
I think very few people on the right
have any respect for anymore but but
their their understanding what you've
pointed out Tim which is that they just
work with these political operatives but
the journalists always present
themselves as the brave fourth estate
speaking truth to power on the front
lines and the irony here is Nat Walsh is
actually one of the most important
journalists in America right Matt Walsh
is doing much more important
journalistic work than any of these
people at any of these liberal
Publications and so they left-wing
political operatives are doing
everything they can to attack an actual
journalist by the name of Matt Walsh I
think Matt's gonna Sue this guy didn't
name him by name but he tweeted an hour
ago I've also made note of the members
of the media openly solicited stolen
information from my phone there I'll be
I'm kind of talking like Matt would talk
to there will be consequences there too
fortunately we can afford very good
lawyers oh wow let me uh let me try and
pull that up that is on his Twitter
account
yeah Matt pulls no punches man
metaphorically spiritually you don't go
after that guy well this is also the the
reason that we sell a lot of chocolate
and razors and why daily wire is a
for-profit company is the only way to
fight back against any of these people
is to have a lot of money that we can
translate into power so that these guys
don't do what they're doing against Matt
or me or Brett Cooper just got booted
from Tick Tock today yeah wow they're
just I don't know this is the last 48
hours has been like open season on The
Daily wire but the reason that we need
to have a lot of money is so that we can
fight back and punish these guys when
they do it so they don't do it against
everybody else could it have anything to
do with the launch of the delicious she
her him chocolate bars by Jeremy's
chocolate I'm more of a he him man
myself uh you know Media Matters is
going to collect but it's good the not
one is very good but the she heard this
is actually yeah it's really good yeah
and I was uh this is actually really
funny I looked on the back of the
ingredients fair trade cocoa butter fair
trade cane sugar dried milk powder fair
trade cocoa powder
soy free
it actually it actually does say soy
seed oils oh really yeah you're right
I'll tell you something so Jeremy
insists that if he is going to tell a
joke it has to be a very very expensive
joke and so we decided early on we could
have just sold schlock kind of products
and people probably would have bought
them and it would have been fun no
we insist upon the highest quality
products that we can can possibly find
there's a lot of crunchy people at DW my
wife is has really pushed for that as
well so it's extraordinarily high
quality stuff it is really good yeah
like no no joke crunchy people like they
like I was just kidding because I was
crunchy I only read that because I saw
the soy free in it
could be adjacent right-wing person yeah
this has been one of the big
realignments is that the when I was
growing up when we were all growing up
the libs were the crunchy people and the
conservatives were just slopping down
all sorts of corporate hormone-injected
food and now it's completely the
opposite it's the libs lining up for
just soy Seed Oil City and it's the
conservatives who are buying the 12 eggs
yeah there was there was like a like a
sea change in 2012 or something about
Barack Obama and people just following
the media narrative and just buying the
Pfizer and buying the Coca-Cola and
doing what Trump you know he loves
McDonald's he loves McDonald's and I
like that he loves McDonald's I agree I
I won't go near it you know he he is
more aspartame now than man I would say
and it has preserved him fairly well so
maybe that's a good argument and a well
done steak that's organic sustains him
no high fructose corn syrup no corn
syrup oh no there's let's see one two
three four ingredients in this thing
that's college educated chocolate right
there well these days I guess probably
not you know let me let me let me read
mad Walsh's statement that I was
actually gonna do that Matt wall said
over the last year my family has been
harassed threatened doxxed and now we
can add hack to the list apparently the
hacker had an Insider who gave him
access to my phone a lot we still don't
know but we're finding out and there
will be consequences he says I have also
made out of the members of the media who
openly solicited stolen information from
my phone there will be consequences
their consequences there too fortunately
we can afford very good lawyers yeah
yeah we're um
we're going to be suing ourselves band
camp
so uh they took down me Bryson gray five
times August probably a couple others
um I don't know how much I should say
though
but uh apparently they're lying publicly
and internally about what happened so we
actually have you know I probably
shouldn't say too much but now I gotta
know you can't just but but for legal
reasons like because we're gonna enter
litigation most likely probably can't
say too much but I guess in this regard
perhaps it would be good that they know
this that we actually uh have received
uh
I'll keep it as light as possible
let's just say I have evidence that
they're spreading uh defamation to
defend to to preempt uh right we were
our our band and several others were
removed without notice we don't know if
they're holding our money we don't know
what's going on and so to justify that
apparently
they're lying about what really happened
but you know we'll see it should come
out in Discovery but I digress I bring
that up simply to point out
very good lawyers from the daily wire
this should need to be taken this is
really important conservatives for a
long time we've just been so nice and I
still think we should be just and do the
right thing and virtuous but we got to
be a little less nice okay I think we
need to start wielding power a little
bit more I think we've got to engage in
lawfare people always think that the
threshold for defamation suits is too
high because of the ridiculous standards
set by New York Times versus Sullivan
one that decision should have been
overturned it's ridiculous it should be
much easier to sue people for
intentionally lying about you but but
two
you can see now when conservatives push
back at all and when we've got a little
power and money behind us people cave
Rolling Stone caved Daily Beast caved
when they defamed me after the CPAC
speech and we're gonna sick the same
kind of lawyers on the people that went
after Men what happened with that when
they defamed you so they came out they
said that I called it CPAC to eradicate
transgender people they rewrote what I
said they put words into my mouth and
then dailybeast called me genocidal so I
tweeted out I said you know this is
defamation this meets the actual malice
standard yeah and I had some pretty
important constitutional lawyers who
agreed with me Senator Mike Lee came out
right away as a supreme court litigator
U.S senator he said this this meets that
standard you should sue these guys a
number of other people did those guys
went running I'm sure the editors got a
call from their lawyers that said you
got to change this because though the
standard is high you have crossed it so
they they caved in two seconds and it
just it just takes a little bit of
Courage I sometimes think that the the
libs they're like the sand people in
Star Wars you know officially
yeah they try to inflate their numbers
they see but they're they're cowards and
they don't they don't have really a lot
on their side so if you just have a
little bit of backbone they're not
impossible to defend and that's so right
and that's why the anhyzer thing I think
is so important because it's the easiest
yeah and you can already see that
Anheuser-Busch is kind of freaking out
about it but I guess in that regard uh
Jeremy's beer one uh listen I texted him
this morning I texted him this morning I
said man I know you're busy you're doing
a million things you have dropped the
ball here okay and you you clearly
there's too much money floating around
the daily wire we we're too cash
positive you gotta burn that money on a
beer company so that we can all learn
something here's what we're gonna do we
here at timcast are going to make a
generic website
and we're going to get a URL that can be
Universal and we'll call it I don't know
like you know uh
something product uh great great product
whatever and then whichever brand makes
the first step over the line in some
kooky wokeness we'll immediately mock up
some graphics drop it on the site and
start selling whatever it is and then
worry about sourcing it later yes of
course of course and the Budweiser thing
here has has been instructive because
yeah Budweiser loses six and a half
billion in market cap they could have
gotten that back if they would just shut
up it's unbelievable they keep changing
their story every single day but I
should apologize it's very they can
apologize but initially they defended it
then they tried to pretend they didn't
know about it then they tried to split
the baby with this crisis communication
stuff then they made that stupid horse
commercial that appealed to nobody and
so they keep blowing it here but the
bigger story I think is not even the the
hit to Anheuser-Busch I think the bigger
story is the hit to Dylan Mulvaney's
brand because I'm not convinced after
this huge unprecedented blowback against
Bud Light do you think other companies
are going to be so quick to sponsor this
guy they made
and there will be some brands that will
do it for sure woke Brands and leftist
companies will absolutely celebrate it
yeah and bigger companies are going to
say look we appreciate you bringing this
offer to us we're not interested at this
time it's going to be very just do the
brand Olay take him on after Bud Light I
thought Olay already had it it's hard
he's got like a dozen sponsorships it's
insane yeah but I I tend to agree with
you Tim I just think six and a half bill
in market cap that's a lot to lose okay
and I I always I think it's important to
stress this point for those who watch
all the episodes you've heard me say it
but just whenever I repeat stuff like
this in multiple episodes I understand
it's because not everyone watches every
show but uh Dylan Mulvaney is not trans
and this was said to me by multiple
trans people citing one very powerful
example Dylan Mulvaney making a video
pointing to his bulge and saying look at
my bulge look at my bulge the issue is
that people who are gender dysphoric
feel pain depression and anxiety from
those those attributes that's what
they're suffering from gender dysphoria
quite literally would be a person saying
like don't look at me don't look at this
part of my body it causes me anxiety
Dill Mulvaney making a video saying met
women have bulges look at my bulge is
the antithesis of what gender dysphoria
is supposed to be Yeah you mentioned
earlier the time for being nice is not
now and I agree because like nice is
like oh someone's gonna say that they're
a girl when it's a guy and I'm like okay
I'll just not say anything because I
want to be nice now be nice it's
different I'm being friendly I'll tell
you to your face what I think but I
still love you that's being friendly and
I think what it is is meekness we need
to be meek which is humble and kind but
carry a big sword and do not mess around
this is something Jordan Peterson has
talked about a lot the meek shall
inherit the earth it's the ones that are
vastly wealthy and not afraid to speak
the truth to someone but also willing to
listen
that's I I think I don't know that
Jordan was the first to say that but I
do like the idea the meek Sean Harris
the Earth yeah that's good yes I think
it's from from the Bible books he was
explaining how people think weak and
meek are the same thing and that's a big
misconception yeah no it's it's a very
important point and you know when we try
to parse the truth of this issue because
I agree Tim there's obviously something
weird going on with Dylan Mulvaney here
that isn't true of all people who have
sexual confusion but there are different
types of transgenderism this is Dr Ray
Blanchard made a point that there he
discovered two different types of
transgender people which is uh
homosexuals who like the idea of being a
woman and uh people with autogynophilia
people who have a sexual fetish who who
are aroused at the prospect of dressing
up like a woman that's in the
traditional cross-dressing the first one
would be gender dysphoria is that what
you're saying well they're both a kind
of a gender dysphoria but that it's it's
a really complex issue a good analogy
for this would be body intake disorder
which body Integrity disorder shares a
lot of the same attributes obviously
it's a defective perception about your
body it is often sets in early on
between the ages of 8 and 12. there may
be some mapping onto the brain to
explain it though a lot of those studies
seem kind of a little shallow as
well and often though not all the time
this disorder is associated with sexual
arousal that it has an association with
a kind of a paraphilia or a sexual
fetish so it's virtually identical well
uh transgender I will add to that
there's three different kinds that I
believe uh that we've seen publicly at
the two you mentioned but then Dylan
Mulvaney represents a third and that is
pseudo gender pseudo transgenderism the
professional actor professional actor
Dylan Mulvaney is just trying to be
famous it's like a Relentless
self-promoters that use transgenderism
as a way to infiltrate institutions of
power that might be a little bit
overthinking it don't move and he's like
I'm going to be famous ooh look at this
it's giving me attention so I'll use
both of those examples let's assume uh I
think it was Michael malice who said
that Dylan Mulvaney is acting out of
fetish and and this probably comes from
Michael's uh personal uh uh friendships
with with trans individuals I thought
you're gonna say his personal
perversions
Michael's friends with some trans people
right and this is probably the
experience his head with them and things
that they've explained to him so is
Dylan Mulvaney acting out of fetish I
don't believe so if it is I think it was
Leah Thomas who was accused of being
what they call AGP Auto gynophilic
meaning that it's a fetish that they are
they're aroused by this
um well Dylan Mulvaney would not be
making a video singing look at my bulge
look at my bulge because the fetishes
look at my look at me I'm a woman right
if it was gender dysphoria where the
person experiences
a set of dysphoria from looking in the
mirror and seeing the wrong body they
also would not sing about their junk
Dylan Mulvaney fundamentally
misunderstanding what transgenderism is
made a video singing women have bulges
because this is just he's like well for
years you know not all trans people have
dysphoria and that's okay not all trans
people take hormones and that's okay and
then essentially anybody can adopt the
identity with zero consequences well I
mean this is just modern wokism and
leftism it just like definitions mean
nothing and but I do want to stress this
post-modernism that book right there you
know I've never actually looked into it
I've seen the screenshots and it's it's
the book genderqueer and uh you will
probably not be surprised to learn that
in the book the woman who claims to be
non-binary explains that she's on an
auto androphile meaning that her desire
to be perceived as a male is rooted in
her sexual arousal from being treated as
a male of course so when this this woman
is a teacher talking to Children telling
them to say that she's a man she
explains it's actually her fetish to be
perceived that way she's including
children in her sexual arousal which I'm
surprised conservatives more concerns
haven't actually looked at this and and
said hey wait a minute first of all it's
kind of hard to look at yeah well
there's a lot in there she couldn't read
till she was 12. it's one of her peeing
in the yard she was not so she was not
socialized properly by her parents she
never shaved her legs she never showered
she would wear crusted dried pads for
for days on end to the point where she
smelled like feces and the school had to
pull her aside say something is wrong
here and then she later got on to
explain how she is sexually aroused at
the thought of being perceived as a man
and that she pushes that onto other
people right I think conservatives would
do a great service understanding that
the libs are open about this though
that's why they say don't kink shame
right don't don't I think now on social
media you're not allowed to make fun of
people's fetishes no matter how weird I
think that's one of the rules on some of
the big Tech platforms and this follows
naturally from the idea that your sexual
desires no matter how deviant are some
wholly protected matter well let's let's
jump to this story actually that you
brought that up this is from timcast.com
Twitter removes portion of hateful
conduct policy that prohibited dead
naming and misgendering transgender
people based the platform has prohibited
using pronouns matching a trans person's
biological sex since 2018. the policy
appears to have been changed on April
8th an archived version of the page from
April 7th still stated those rules the
last sentence has since been removed and
said the policy now States the platform
prohibits targeting others with repeated
slurs tropes or other content that
intends to degrade or reinforce negative
or harmful stereotypes about a protected
category I'm just going to say it again
I know I'm the low guy on the totem pole
in this regard but Elon Musk Joe Rogan
me having a follow-up to the Jack Dorsey
Vegeta episode we did I think would be
absolutely tremendous uh but like I said
I'm the low guy obviously I'd love to be
sitting in a room with Elon and Joe
Rogan but uh at least I can say that
follow-up I think would be very
important because this was a core
component of it it's so important too
you think about there's this guy Charles
climber who is a trans activist and he's
very far left I think he worked for the
Human Rights Campaign he worked for this
ridiculous group called Catholics for
Choice a pro-abortion Catholic roof yeah
not the most coherent kind of a group
and if the policy were in place that you
couldn't refer to Charles climber you
have to call him whatever girl name he
goes by it this would be very convenient
for Charles because he has a bit of a
dodgy past back when he was Charles and
got into some political scandals so if
you're not allowed to refer to Charles
all of a sudden wow how nice all of
these all of these problems and Scandals
go away I Google search away exactly
well I think the other issue with it is
where is the line in what someone is
allowed to identify as and this is a
huge component so uh back in I think
2018 I was looking at New York City's
laws and they protect by they identify
31 genders but the law explicitly States
infinite genders exist because it
defines gender expression as
self-expression and so they say that you
can't discriminate in public
accommodations based on the clothing a
person wears the name they go by
and if that's the case what is the legal
limit so I ask a human rights lawyer and
they said well obviously there's a
reasonableness expectation in the law
the assumption is with this law it's if
a person is transgender they're you know
discernably male but wearing a dress you
can't fire them if they're certainly
male but going by the name Susan you
can't fire them and so I asked a a
couple human rights lawyers
if somebody went to Starbucks and
um applied for a job that showed up on
day one in a fursuit and they called
themselves vociferon Herald of the
winter Mists would Starbucks be able to
fire them for this and they said yes of
course that's ridiculous and I said well
why why can't they sue under that very
same law that that is their gender
expression
and what I was told was a judge would
laugh them out of the courtroom and then
I said what if the judge doesn't like
trans people and laughs at the man in a
dress what's the difference and they
didn't have an answer well and you know
the the case that established a lot of
this is that Harris Funeral Home case
from just a few years ago in in which
we're talking about a funeral home here
so the customers at funeral homes are
very very vulnerable they're grieving
their loved ones and there was this dude
who decided that he wants to be a chick
and so he started wearing skirts to work
and the owner of the funeral home said
uh hey man I don't know what you're
getting into but you know you've got to
have some respect for them
this isn't about you man you know this
is about the the people who are mourning
and he sued him went all the way up to
the Supreme Court and and the Supreme
Court decided that that man that man's
sexual fetish was more important than
people's right to mourn but think about
how crazy this is if you have a funeral
home the issue is not that we don't like
that you're wearing a dress I mean Celts
exist they're similar in a certain
respect but we're talking about you
respecting someone whose loved one died
and there's formal attire requirements
with New York City's law they've
basically abolished uniforms
it says you can't discriminate based on
what someone wears in public combination
so if I show up at Starbucks wearing a
clown costume let's just be reasonable
I'll show up wearing jeans and a t-shirt
and say you can't make me wear those
clothes because those are man clothes
yeah they can't do anything about it the
the the astounding thing however to me
was and this is a honestly a big uh
Revelation for me in understanding law a
judge will laugh a person out of a
courtroom and then I said then there
will be many judges who are going to see
a man wearing a dress and laugh and say
get out of my courtroom this is
ridiculous where's the line and what I
was told is well judge make judges make
those determinations that they're
they're the human interpretation of the
law and then I went interesting the law
doesn't matter the only thing that does
is the culture if the culture tolerates
men and women cross-dressing in public
then the judge will defend it if the
culture tolerates fursuits the judge
will defend it and right now it seems
the fursuit goes over the line but I'd
say in three or four years of course you
will see people in full fursuits at
Starbucks serving your coffee of course
and notice when you say we've now got
the abolition of uniforms this is always
the result of these kind of leftist
policies that specifically focused on
trans right now but all of these leftist
policies is this constant leveling and
lowering down and abolition of Standards
so the answer that people give the
middle ground on the bathrooms is what
you said earlier which is well let's
just all have unisex bathrooms and we'll
just all have individual bathrooms
what's the answer on the sports teams
we'll just have we'll all just have our
own sports teams or something what's the
answer and and so what happens is we all
just become this undifferentiated
androgynous consumer that's all we do
all we are now is is I don't want to
sound like a commie or something but
this is being pushed not just by the
leftist activists it's being pushed by
the entire liberal establishment and by
Corporate America and the whole power
structure which is just to take away all
the ornamentation all the
differentiation all the natural lovely
diversity of life and make us all just a
bunch of blobs to buy a bunch of
hormones and purchase their products and
uniform actually means the same one form
that's what uniform is for is to make
all the same so they're stripping away
the Communist sameness of everything to
create a weird world to then reconfigure
it so that everyone yeah instead of
having different kinds of uniforms in
different areas of life are different
for men and women now it's literally we
will just be uniform undifferentiated
blobs plugged into our computers and
living in in the metaverse and eating
eyes I think that's absolutely where
we're going uh the the Deep fakery is
getting so Advanced so rapidly
last time I was on Rogan I said I didn't
think it was that big of a deal and I
was so wrong and and so naive because I
was looking at the Modern iterations of
deep fakes and I was just like I'm not
worried about that I didn't stop to
consider the rapid degree of Advance how
long ago was that when you run this was
a year and a half ago year and a half
think about how fast right so far in six
months a year and a half ago there was
like one program that had accomplished
voice manipulation and there were some
goofy videos that were low-res and I was
just like I'm not worried about this
and then within a year and a half it
Advanced to the point where I I was on
Instagram
and I saw a Rogan clip and it's Joe
advertising some uh I think it's like a
I think it was penis growth or something
like that some weird like testosterone
booster thing and uh I was like whoa it
was if you if you if you watched it
you're like that's a deep fake if you
were just passing through you might not
have noticed and that's when I was like
oh man now we have that 11 Labs website
where you can take 30 seconds of anyone
talking drop it in and you can make them
say whatever you want now I'm like
imagine what it's going to be like in a
year
there is going to be a defect of Donald
Trump giving a speech that looks
completely real he will say something
kind of bad but not really that bad but
bad enough to lose votes and no matter
what anyone says the left will believe
it I wonder if it'll get to the point
where there will be two presidents
according to everyone and no one will
know which one's the real one and which
one's the fake that's a good point
because yes because someone will make a
deep fake clip of CNN and put it on
Twitter by a verification and then it'll
be Don Lemon saying Donald Trump has
been re-elected this 2024 and then
people are going to see the clips and
they're going to believe it I mean
that's gonna happen this AI stuff is
actually the end of society I know
people like to claim that all sorts of
advancements and Innovations are the end
of society this one actually is because
it impels people to just Retreat into
themselves for everything so now we will
Retreat into our own fantasies for art
it makes great art so the art that I put
up on my walls I can just type it into
mid-journey or any of them and get a
beautiful piece of art it will you'll be
able to create these these deep fakes of
video and audio it's obviously going to
be applied to porn I assume it actually
probably already is being applied to
porn is it yeah and I'm sure in the
future I'm sure it will be and so people
will have no reason to engage in reality
because one you won't have any common
referent to talk about you'll just have
I'll have my video of trump and you'll
have your video of trump and we'll both
have made them up we we I'll have my
fantasy that I'm living in be it uh
personal be it uh entertainment be it be
it sex be it anything and we'll all just
we'll all just be living in our pods
plugged into our own fantasies that is
the end of community the only thing I
can think that would change that or one
of the things is if the power goes out
and I don't want the power to go out but
if it did then the artificial
intelligence would die I'm not laughing
at you I'm sorry but but there's ways to
make potential electricity that's why
solar wind geothermal not tapping the
vacuum I mean it's
because they want to create my my pitch
I actually pitched this uh half pitched
it to you guys with the daily wire an
idea for a show where I'll try and give
the super simple version
it takes place in a world that's like
human civilizations collapse there's
only one city left and it's people it's
like the year 2130 technology is
comparable to it to what it is now a
conflict emerges between very thin tall
humanoid beings and white jumpsuits with
chrome heads who can shoot lasers humans
fight
no one knows how civilization collapsed
but they assume these creatures must
have wiped out the planet become some
some kind of aliens and then in the
final episode of the Season or whatever
you know there's a fight and then
someone hits like a magnet a crane
release which drops a boulder or car
onto one of these creatures and crushes
it disabling its force fields they pull
the Chrome helmet off and oh it's a
human and the reveal is that Society
didn't collapse it migrated underground
into pods where humans all Network
themselves with norlinks into a virtual
world and the reason why the last city
was unaware of what happened to humanity
is the news didn't stop news was still
being written but it migrated my example
is if someone came from the year 1900 to
this time period they'd immediately be
like get me a newspaper so I can learn
about what's happening in the world and
then they would find that newspaper
slowly started to disappear if they if
if someone from the 1900s jumped 200
years in the future and then just try to
take a look at history based on their
understanding of how to look their
history they would be like newspapers
ceased to exist in the year 2075 5
history was gone we have no idea what
happened humans no I just went online so
my my idea for this show is there will
be some humans who never migrate and
they will not have access to the the
metaverse historical archive so to them
they'll just like their their great
grandchildren will be like we don't know
exactly what happened but some kind of
collapse happened and we have no access
we just find these old records these old
websites and stuff and servers we try to
boot up and figure out where where where
they all went the problem for those
metaverse records though is that when
everything is digital you can just
constantly change the records this is
the one of the Prophecies of 1984. and
that's actually a component like this
show would be fantastic because the
people who live in the metaverse would
have a warped view of reality because
there would be oligarchs who rewrite
history but then the people who live in
the real world with the physical
unalterable will like meet one of these
people in the metaverse and be like look
at these archives that we've brought and
they're like that's not history and
they'll pull up Wikipedia to show
history and it'll be last edited
yesterday and they'll be like this book
hasn't been re-edited in 300 years this
is all very scary but I think what Mark
Zuckerberg is trying to sell is like
what if you had Zoom meetings but you
were an octopus
and I'm just like I don't know what to
do with this information well Ian
mentioned earlier like you could
identify as a carrot you know yeah like
you're gonna you're gonna go you're
gonna be in the metaverse on on Tinder
and you're gonna be like a carrot a dog
a toaster a a VW
oh a person swipe from the person even
that gets back to the trans thing like
everything else today which is that in
the metaverse did you see Mark
Zuckerberg cut everyone off at the navel
so initially
they kept sexually harassing each other
so they just cut their legs off is that
what happened yeah on the beta testing
they kept pinching each other and things
they had to chop off their sacks just
again just don't take away their legs it
is you're I think you brought that the
word trans because of the transhumanism
movement well that's what it's all about
ultimately and the word says is from the
mathematical term trans and sis
Alpine Gall trans Alpine golf the
billionaires are all super into the
transhumanist stuff and because they're
evil they don't want to die
and that's an incredibly dark impulse
and that's why they're kind of getting
behind all the transgenderous stuff
because yeah that's totally true mental
step a lot of these guys are pretty
intelligent but sometimes intelligent
people are just the dumbest people on
Earth for all of human history really
rich selfish people have tried to figure
out how to live forever and we're living
in such a stupid time that we're this
has been going on for all of history and
people now go online and they say wow
you know we're really close to living
forever this time we've almost figured
it out spoiler alert they're not going
to figure it out that's not a real thing
you're just gonna kill a bunch of people
in the process yes trying to find out
you're going to kill a bunch of people
you're going to cause all sorts of havoc
and it's that same Lie from the Garden
of Eden which is the lie that ye shall
be as Gods Ferrari refers to this as
homo Deus that we're now going to take
control over the future of humanity and
you think okay good luck buddy I mean
unfortunately it's going to cause lots
of problems in the short term but it
ain't gonna work man I think we need to
get the daily wire crew we we might have
to force them to watch Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood it's an anime and
uh but I'll just spoil it for you right
now to explain I was just about to watch
it Attack on Titan is also really good
uh and I'll tell you why full metal uh
Alchemist Brotherhood is about a
basically this entity that wants to
sacrifice humans to become immortal to
to to ascend to a higher plane and so
it's just government conspiracy to
murder people and sacrifice them so uh
that I think is interesting there's
something like Matt Walsh said about
like not watching anime and then there
was like a backlash from people like no
there's some good stories here and
Attack on Titan is about
ancestral crimes and how certain races
of people should be held criminally
responsible for things their answers did
thousands of years ago so that's they're
interesting stories that I think yeah
what the Italians did those poor
Etruscans those poor Etruscans oh yeah
dude Etruscans let's rock and roll
that's where that's the Romans took
credit for all that stuff the Etruscans
actually are where it's at I found I was
reading the sub stack of Pope head the
other day great sub stack and I saw this
quote from Seneca the philosopher Seneca
and it was about the difference between
the Romans and the Etruscans and Seneca
said the difference between us Romans
and those Etruscans is the the Romans
look at Clouds creating rain and they
say Okay Natural Forces came together
and they put the clouds and then the
rain came and then here's some meaning
that we could infer from that but those
Etruscans who attribute everything to
the Divine they believe that the gods
wanted to express meaning and so they
pushed the clouds together and had the
rainfall and the thing is the Etruscans
were totally right have you ever moved
clouds with your magnetic field I have
not I am not a God you can oh you are
well it's flowing through you you
utilize the magnetic fields I think
you're wrong I think my field is a
little off we talked with Alex Jones
about this and uh you you weren't in the
room though but I could hear uh I could
hear the screaming from Ian downstairs
yeah Alex so Ian likes talking about the
magnetic yields all the time yeah but
Alex Jones actually mentioned that they
did experiments and found there is some
kind of energy around all of us moving
through us that it's it's uncontrollable
that uh I I don't know exactly how he
described it I was basically saying it
it does connect all of us in some way
but you can't control it just because
something hasn't been controlled doesn't
mean it can't be that's an important
differential you know what I think
I should say you know to hypothesize
sometimes that if there really is this
connection to the the greater or
whatever that people probably don't all
have the exact same connection and
probably to varying degrees some people
I I wonder if the reason why you have
woke NPC type people
and some people who seem to be smarter
more perceptive is simply because
they're called whatever you want third
eye or antenna is more receptive to you
know this kind of energy or whatever
that is to say if you are closed off
from the greater from the spiritual from
whatever prayer is meaningless to you
you don't experience it you haven't
there is nothing Beyond this reality
you're a moist robot and that's all that
there is but if you're someone who has a
greater connection to whatever you want
to call it the spiritual realm or to God
or whatever you're going to understand
and know things and you also can't give
that feeling to a person who doesn't
have that well of course because it's
not about you I mean we used to just
call this sanctity and so I loved when
you brought up earlier the simulation
Theory because simulation theory is just
the way that modern people talk about
basic religious Concepts and overall
that doesn't accept religion and so and
the way we talk about the magnets and
the fields and whatever but yeah we're
talking about Holiness and we're talking
about spiritual reality and so of course
it's the case that some people are are
Holier or other people and more attuned
to this but the thing is you can grow in
Holiness and you can also turn away from
the grace of God and when you say well
you can't give it to someone else that's
because it's about your relationship
with God it's not about your
relationship with some other dude I had
a guy tell me a story that he uh became
Christian because he was doing drugs he
was in the woods and then he woke up in
the morning strung out hungover went to
go take a leak and then all of a sudden
felt this booming voice from within his
own chest say what are you doing and it
freaked him out and then it said you are
wasting your life you have to stop this
you have to change and he didn't know
what it was so he went and sought
answers and then found you know holy men
who explained to him what this was what
it meant he got clean started a business
and lived a fulfilling life with his
friends and became very responsible and
he went from a strung out drug addict
wasting away into a productive member of
society after having this profound
moment and he said to me I don't care if
you don't believe me it happened to me
and I can never get give you that
feeling but I assure you I experienced
it oh of course I was like no I believe
you it was a voice that sounded like why
Saul of Tarsus are you persecuting me
these things happen people have those
road to Damascus moments yeah and you
know some and and I'm sure the secular
atheist types might just say well he was
on drugs he was having a psychotic break
or whatever and I'll be like call it
whatever you want explain it however you
want this person had a experience where
they felt something that changed their
life for the better I I'm totally okay
with that I think sometimes your frontal
lobe clouds your your spiritual part of
the brain maybe because when it quiets
when you can go into Flow State and and
dim the activity in your frontal lobe is
when you really time starts to lose
meaning I think it can kind of happen
and there's so much activity like
stimulating the frontal lobe my name who
am I I exist in my frontal lobe without
that you're kind of part of it do you
wonder Ian though if you're if you're
confusing the physical for the
metaphysical like you're you're talking
about this as if your brain is
controlling everything as if the
physical world is controlling uh some
aspect of your metaphysical
understanding but what if those two
things are just occurring simultaneously
or if or if what if it's going in the
opposite Direction so now we we say all
the time I had such an adrenaline rush
we don't say I got excited right we say
I had oh I got a dopamine hit instead of
I felt happy but why is the physical the
only meaningful thing when in fact the
physical world alone can't have any
meaning let me let me bridge this with
science people who do DMT and break
through the veil and then see some other
kind of entity Beyond this realm usually
demons well but maybe but you can call
them demons but why make that assumption
some of them may be demons what if some
of them are more holy or something like
well I got I actually had a great
interview there's a little bit of a plug
up for my YouTube channel I had this
two-hour interview with a guy who was a
total psychonaut all into
psychotropics and hallucinogens and he
he thinks they're demons but it's worth
if people want to go watch it's a
two-hour conversation but yeah I'd be
more inclined to believe they were
demons to be honest but um at the same
time a bit more agnostic on whatever
people experience this whatever they
could be but the only reason I bring it
up is because if if it is true that MO
multiple people I mean hundreds or
thousands of people have experienced
some kind of consistent entity by taking
this this chemical than when you Ian
like as you were saying you you conflate
the metaphysical with the physical when
you experience these things it could be
something Beyond the Veil reaching into
yeah I think I focus on the physical a
lot because I feel like that's what I
can control in the in the process that
like it's like a radio tuner I can tune
it to the right frequency but I'm not
making the music happen
um so
I say I'm just so evidence-based so I'm
looking at like but I think the magnetic
field it's like moving around the
magnetic field I I believe you can but
it's like if you have a magnet in your
hand and you're moving it underneath
underneath a piece of paper with all
these iron fragments on top of the paper
the iron's moving but are you moving the
iron or are you moving the magnet you're
moving the magnet the the iron filings
are just moving I think you're I think
you're still making the same
epistemological error though which is
you're you're saying that you're
evidence-based and so you want to ground
everything physically but the error here
is the idea that reality is
fundamentally physical which it
certainly is not the fact that we have
intelligible speech that the fact that
symbols have meaning that we it can
interpret and that we rely on it all it
tells you that the reality is
fundamentally metaphysical and there's
evidence
that's physical too yeah I got that I
got this because Ian you're a fan of
Incubus I love Incubus and Brandon Boyd
what's up dog and they have that song
where
um I don't know if it's which song it
has a Certain Shade of Green or
something like that where in the middle
of the song There's a recording of a guy
who says at the turn of the century
humans thought that what they could
touch smell see in here was reality but
since the initial publication of the
charged electro magnetic spectrum humans
have learned that what they can touch
smell see in here are less than is less
than one millionth of reality
so there you go it's a good that's a
good line actually from Incubus which is
a kind of a demon yeah when you talk
about it it literally as it is literally
when you talk about physics what's
physical they used to think of solid
liquid and gas and then all of a sudden
at some point they realize oh plasma is
a fourth state of physical matter
there's more there's more physical stuff
than we realized and when you look at
Clouds of plasma moving around I don't
think they're intelligent but there
seems to be a sentience involved with
the way that plasma like it doesn't move
like a cloud in the air well you you
you're a physical thing and you are
sentient also but the sentience isn't
isn't from your your Consciousness your
rationality is not from your physical
body that's you're just a clump of cells
in your physical body that your your
reason comes from your rationalism I'll
put it this way we're we're uh we're
playing a video game
it's not a simulation it's a video game
and we are entities that exist beyond
the physical bodies but we are occupying
them to facilitate this simulated
experience in plasma clouds there's
these things called plasmon in the
center of plasma clouds and when they're
hit with photons with light it causes
the plasma Cloud to react so it's like
it's like information is being
transferred from light into plasma which
is then cooling down into gas and then
into liquid and then into solid but that
doesn't that doesn't have to be a
conscious process physical things react
to stimuli right where it seems like a
sentient process not necessarily
conscious but like if I if I threw let's
say I threw an explosive like those
people last night if I threw an
explosive at that wall the wall would
react and there'd be a hole in the wall
or a dent in the wall but the Wall's not
conscious I think you're right I think
Consciousness is like is like living
organisms seem to have Consciousness not
necessarily organisms because they don't
be carbon based but like living things
have Consciousness but unliving things
have sentience it seems like like when
they say God is I don't think God is
conscious I think it's sentient well so
God is consciousness right God is reason
uh uh but if we're talking about
sentience in the sense that uh one can
feel Sensations you know like a an
animal or even simpler organisms can
react to certain stimuli you know they
can feel pain say
um that's true and when we talk about
Consciousness we're usually talking
about rational Consciousness so we can
discuss abstract things you know we can
talk about justice but an ape or a or a
plant can't talk about Justice right I I
think Ian desperately wants to believe
in God he does he does every time I'm
here I just think you're like you're so
close but you keep falling into all this
but we're talking about a different
thing when God because if there's a
conscious God he's looking for a
personal relationship with us as
individuals and if there's a God who's
not conscious but he's sentient somehow
no no but what I'm saying is the
questions Ian asks sound more like a
please make me understand totally yeah
totally I used to be agnostic and then I
saw the cosmic microwave background
radiation I was like okay I I'm evidence
guy that is evidence of God that is like
looks like a neural but everything is I
mean I remember I had this when I was an
atheist I was sitting out having a cigar
in my little front porch and I had this
tiny little house in in New York and I
had this dead rose bush what the thing
was all it wasn't like a beautiful thing
that I was looking at but I just I was
sitting there and I was looking at the
leaves and the complexity of the leaves
on on this dying rose bush and I thought
you know
there's got to be some logic here
there's got to be why is that so complex
why is that conveying meaning to me even
this totally quotidian thing and it
wasn't it wasn't the the biggest push in
my becoming a Christian and believing
that God exists but it was another piece
of evidence which is the the evidence of
meaning and intelligence is all around
us it's here it's even in the stupid
book genderqueer that Fibonacci Sequence
that golden ratio keeps showing up in
reality well yeah because there's a
structure to the universe there's a
logic and there's a math and we're only
like you're like wow the golden ratio is
everywhere but in reality it's just you
noticing a tiny little piece of the
logic of the universe that exists
sometimes I wonder if I'm looking
through the lens of the spiraling Galaxy
there's three types of galaxies there's
irregular galaxies which is like a star
cluster then they become a spiral galaxy
where it starts to spin then they form
up into a spheroid Galaxy and I feel
like we're in a transition towards the
spheroid but I wonder if because we're
in a spiral other things look like
they're spiraling so we're only seeing
the Fibonacci sequence from our
perception because we're wearing spiral
glass perhaps so I I will dive into the
subject matter just because it came up
and I think it's a good opportunity with
having you here because uh Sheamus will
be back uh next week so we're really
excited for Sheamus Coughlin of Freedom
Tunes we'll be hanging out Seamus is
going to be the one to actually get you
Ian I I can maybe push a little bit on
the Apologetics but Sheamus is a Shiite
wahhabi Catholic was it cancer for
absolutely everything he is he's a very
but uh I wanna I wanna I wanna make this
point for those that haven't heard it
um because we briefly mentioned that
simulation theory is the language used
by you know how to describe it it's just
the way modern people talk about
religion because they don't know how to
talk about religion so it's it just
seems more relatable for people when uh
when I was in Catholic school and we
were learning about science and we were
learning about uh energy and I was told
that you know to realize energy cannot
be created or destroyed uh it can only
be changed energy is and always has been
and I was like it sounds very similar to
how you describe God or or the universe
or things like that it just sounds like
you you're talking about something
similar and they never really gave me a
good philosophical understanding of any
kind of similarities or what it could
possibly mean but as a kid who was nine
years old I certainly took that to heart
and considered maybe what they mean is
like maybe back when they wrote this
stuff when the Bible was being written
when people when holy men were studying
and coming with ideas they were they
were conveying their understanding of
the universe without our modern
sensibilities so that brings us to
simulation Theory
where you get people who are seemingly
atheists saying I kid you not a more
advanced entity than us created this
universe for a purpose with rules and
expects something from us and then I'm
like I can't tell if you're a holy man
or a stimulus are are you attack bro
from Silicon Valley or are you someone
trying to explain the rudimentary
religion to me the simulation language
that people use now if it if it
persuades anyone it's fine by me but
it's it's better even than the idea of
energy you you recognized a similarity
between something in the created world
and the creator of that world but the
the idea that God just is synonymous
with the world or that God it just is
the world and there's a little God left
over which is called penen theism that
is that is different from the Christian
idea and the monotheism and the way
things really are the simulation theory
is a better mapping of that because you
have God who is entirely self-sufficient
who does not need us who creates the
world in this act of Love out of nothing
and makes us in his own image that is in
the modern way we talk about it just
some geeky programmer who like makes us
now get this I often hear people say
something like well if God created the
universe who created God and it's just
like well hold on now you're ascribing
our physical limitations to something
that is beyond our physical limitations
but here's a better way to explain it
all y'all have played The Sims I have
all four of them are the Sims smart
enough to comprehend this reality or
existence Sims aren't smart exactly but
they do their little thing they live in
their little Universe they don't have a
degree of Consciousness they are not
smart we
that's us yeah we are the Sims we are
the very stupid bumbling around and then
we cannot comprehend what exists Beyond
do you believe when you think about
Destiny and free will do you think that
we're just destined to play a part in
this chemical reaction
I I think
the likely uh I wouldn't say I'm as
definitive as Michael but I believe
we're here for a reason I believe the
universe was created for a purpose I
believe that it's entirely possible the
universe is actually only 5 000 years
old and that is I'm not saying I believe
it hold on I'm saying it's possible if
you are someone who believes in
simulation Theory the idea being you've
played uh you play Grand Theft Auto oh
yeah that was the only video game as a
teenager that I played because it was
just so shocking not not let me I want
to point this out uh when you play Grand
Theft Auto you know there is no point in
that video game where people built
buildings yeah where our construction
crew came in and constructed a
skyscraper it just always has been and
the that Universe was created
specifically in the year 2013 or
whatever and it just came into existence
and so I find it fascinating that people
who believe in simulation Theory can't
understand the same argument from a
religious perspective that the Universe
was created five thousand years I don't
like that argument I used to think that
nothing existed unless I was perceiving
that everything was a wave of infinite
possibility outside of our perception
and my perception collapsed reality and
this is just a simulation I'm
experiencing it was very egocentric it's
called solipsism and other people were
like Ian you freak I'm part of this too
like what's wrong where did you go
you're not the Ian I used to know and so
I think it it's possible that it's both
that and everyone's experiencing that
and but it because of that we're all it
is all real but we're also it's all a
wave of infinite possibility I mean it
is possible aren't those mutually
contradictory exactly yes yeah so they
can't simultaneously well they can't
contradictions can exist in nature
no what well like Quantum Computing
allows something to be a one and a zero
at the same moment
yes
that's true you're saying that there are
you're saying that there are
possibilities that can collapse down
into actualities that's the quantum the
physical person Quantum physical
perception of like the I don't know
double I don't want to misquote the
double slit experiment but things were
like electrons work as function as a
cloud until you put a perception on them
then they collapse into their where
they're at but you don't know where
they're gonna be at until you look yeah
but now but what you're suggesting is
now I'm always a little hesitant when
people bring up Quantum things because I
just find
you know physics is very hard and I I
because uh all of the quantum language
is so Fantastical people tend to turn
them to their own ideological or uh
theological purposes so I'm a little
cautious with it but is is are you
suggesting that scientists have
discovered a way to violate Aristotle's
law of non-contradiction uh I'm not
familiar with there which is the idea
that that mutually contradictory things
can't simultaneously exist well I kind
of like uh women's bathrooms and
transgenderism well I disagree because I
think someone could be a man and a trans
woman at the same time but not a female
correct they've given a female or trans
man but they're still both in this
regard what we're currently what we if
assuming you believe all of the
companies that have claimed this Quantum
Computing is uh right so computers
operate with yes and no Gates ones and
zeros Quantum Computing allows the the
calculation to exist as a one in the
zero in the same space at the same time
so the calculations happen rapidly oh
sure sure so I I understand I understand
the not rapidly but instantaneous right
right no I understand that from the
perspective of rapidity but I don't
really understand and we're speaking in
language that is figurative even when we
talk about ones and zeros I don't really
understand what it means for these uh
contradictory things to be something
another contradiction so basically
contradictions right well let me let me
explain if uh let's let's say you want
to brute force a password right yeah
imagine it like you have uh an ant farm
yeah when you when you're looking
through the glass you can see all these
little paths and trails that go all the
way down in little shapes like a maze
yeah if you were to try and send in one
drop of water at a time to navigate that
maze it gets blocked another up it gets
blocked that's brute forcing to get to
the bottom yeah Quantum Computing would
be cool right water straight in the tops
of the whole it goes and it instantly
gets you to the bottom and getting that
access here's an example of a
contradiction a simple contradiction
like when you look at that number what
number do you see well I see nine I see
a six but you see us and we're both
right
well no we just we don't know which way
is the top of the paper I don't think
there is a top of the paper there is a
top of the paper but who's told who's
going to decide well I can tell you I've
got good evidence for it so let me
I'm pleased to say that I'm right about
what the number is uh because I can see
that the the paper was pulled from your
notebook now this way oh you're wrong
I'm wrong yes look with the margin on
the paper is okay you're right I got you
if if I were more observant and more
scientific I would have noticed where
the margin was on the paper what did you
say you said nine you flip it yeah so
there it is the margins at the top six
yep it's the six listen I don't I'm a
modern person you were right it is a
nine from your perspective perspective
no I I unfortunately Tim was right and I
was wrong and you were right
but the reason is there there the paper
has a Direction objectively This what I
can know using my perception and using
my reason where the paper came from what
the orientation of the paper is and once
I know that I can know if this is a six
or a nine and Ian I'll be the bigger man
you were right so I assume there was no
paper it was just outside in the
wilderness You Came Upon that symbol it
doesn't there's no relativism it just
your your perception is what it is no no
hold on let me let me let me answer this
for you Ian uh let me see the paper yeah
so the the way we deduced that this was
in fact a six and not a nine is first
Michael tried to point out the tear and
he assumed it came from this side of the
of the paper but you were holding it
upside down so you assumed it came this
way in fact Ian pulled it out from the
other side the margin is at the Top If
the margin was not there and we couldn't
determine what it was that doesn't mean
it is a six it is a nine it means we
don't have enough evidence to form the
correct conclusion but it is a six and
it is a nine no no both at once that's
the correct contradiction of reality
that can exist uh Ian I I disagree and
I'll explain if someone were to write a
password onto a piece of paper and they
wrote 666 and it was a square Post-It
note that with no sticky it was like a
square piece of paper and they dropped
it somewhere it was intended the
intention and the code itself is 666
meaning if you want to unlock the door
it's 666. someone comes upon that paper
and they say I don't know the
orientation of the paper
it may be nine it may be six the answer
is I don't know not that it's not
because I choose it to be because then
if you go to the keep at Terminal type
999 doorway you're applying relativism
if there's no nothing to relate it to
you you just have to take it but but in
in objective reality there are things to
relate it to and to grounded in so I'll
use Tim's example there's the adhesive
line on the sticky so that could give
you some evidence of which weight is now
let's say the adhesive rubbed off well
you're gonna have to look and see is
there a little hint of that adhesive
left or maybe it got ripped off unless
the intention of the individual was to
make an obscure symbol to confuse people
the it is either a six or a nine I think
our inability to understand the intent
of the person who who crafted that
symbol does not negate what the symbol
sometimes in nature there is no intent
it just is and and the experience of
being human is our attempt to
rationalize there's always intent there
is well and always purpose and tea loss
and and and and let's let's take it one
step further again if this symbol
appeared on a tree because a Lightning's
lightning struck it and then it was
sideways and someone came up and said is
it a six a nine an e well I think it's a
six well I think it's a nine the reality
is it's a mark from a lightning strike
it's all three of those it's not it's
not it surely is yes in order for it to
be the symbol you describe it as it must
relate to the language the abstract
ideological structure of the person
ascribed it to if a fish flops on the
ground and draws this symbol I'm not
going to say that fish just wrote a
number for me I'm going to say the fish
flopped to the ground kinda looks like a
six kind of looks like a nine but you're
establishing a lot of relative aspects
to the the cut the position like if if
someone walks into nature and that is
just on the ground it depends on what if
you come at it from one side it looks
like a nine if you come in from that it
looks like a six what you're really
getting at here is is a distinction
between the way actually that the left
and the right view the world which is as
one of a world of interpretation or a
world of activism and the imposition of
will so the idea of law actually the
idea of whether that's a six or a nine
the conservatives would look at that and
say look there is objective reality
there is an intelligibility to the
universe I have a faculty of reason and
so I can interpret and I can learn
things from the world whereas the way
that the modern left the very
relativistic self-centered left and very
willful wrathful left would look at that
and say I don't give a damn what it's
supposed to mean I'm going to deny my
faculties of reason I'm going to pretend
that men are actually women I'm going to
say that babies aren't really babies and
it's going to be whatever the hell I
want let me pull this into this analogy
the right takes the approach I think
that you and I described Michael Ray
where you'll see the symbol and they'll
say how did the symbol come to be and
what meaning does it intend to convey
the symbol exists I would like to
understand why it exists the left's
perspective is there's a symbol I'm
going to tell you what I want it to be
but it's a Humpty Dumpty right words can
mean whatever I want them but whatever
empowers me which is what political
correctness is too the right using
rationality I I think that is a good
method towards describing meaning but no
no to interpreting me to interpreting
not describing meaning but to interpret
it and so you incredibly rational
brilliant probably stop it Jesus level
IQ was certain that was a nine after a
moment of examining the situation using
your rationality that was one of the few
times that I've been wrong
the most brilliant no rationalists can't
be wrong yes and being wrong does not
mean it is wrong the thing is though you
weren't wrong you were right that wasn't
trying to make me feel better I was
wrong man you were right and you were
right and I was right no it was at six
or nine and of scratch mark on paper it
actually isn't Ian you took a piece of
paper with the margin the top and you
wrote a six well I drew that shape I
wanted to see what number he thought it
was I thought it was a six so the point
is the I think in the culture where this
is actually a great conversation for
people who are listening this is I think
it's important to understand the left's
predominant view versus what we would
describe as the right the right includes
post-liberals because the political
factions are no longer about policy it's
now about in understanding reality and I
grew up traditionally liberal uh I think
you did too right Michael oh yeah I'm
from New York I mean everybody was now
you're now you're uh theistic Christian
conservative yeah I don't know what I am
some kind of ism you know but I mean I I
grew up I was always kind of a young
Republican type you know I had a little
liberal phase but to your point Tim even
being a young Republican conservative
type
but pretty much meant we were all
liberals for much of the last 30 years
so so I I like this this analogy this
this way to break down the the
way people see the world and when I see
the symbol I look for the evidence the
way you drew this Ian on this paper with
the paper's margin on top is how you
would typically make a six therefore you
drew a six you can call whatever you
want I understand for this purpose you
are not intending to make it either
symbol the left does two things the
first they jump to conclusions and then
insist they know because of ego when
they see the piece of paper they will
say it's whatever they want it to be a
nine or a six whatever suits their needs
at the time
they are unwilling typically to listen
to any evidence the typical leftist
perspective on this would be hey look at
that margin on top that means to six
well if that's offending their ego
because they determine to be a nine
they'll say you are wrong and they'll
make a similar argument to to you which
is called sophistry an attempt to make a
fallacious argument to prove them right
for the sake of their dominance over you
because they believe there's no truth
but I don't think it is I'm pointing out
that it's it's both a six and a nine
that's not sophistry that's just an
observation right right and what I'm
what I'm explaining to you is
on a piece of paper with this
orientation you have drawn a six I mean
that's not what Michael told me 10
minutes Michael because I was wrong but
but you said you were okay but well no
you're wrong
I'm just going to be clear this is this
is my this is my point yeah you actually
didn't you actually drew a six I mean
that's an upside down nine man flip it
upside down it's actually not it's an
ugly looking nine but it sure is you
drew this from that's how I draw you
that's not how you make nines I mean so
my point is simply this honestly I was
drawing a six yes you were thank you
you're saying there is I thought you
might think it was a nine yeah and if I
wish there was a square white piece of
paper you succeeded at deceiving me in
but this this actually this gets to
exactly what was going on last night at
Pittsburgh by the way we were supposed
to have a debate and conservatives are
more inclined to have debates and
debates are about pursuing logic to come
to the truth and the libs were outside
throwing explosives and that's and
actually this gets back down to the
Bible you know there's an important
moment in the Bible when Christ goes in
and he's hanging out with these two
ladies Mary and Martha and one of the
sisters is sitting contemplating what
Christ is saying and the other sister is
serving the lunch and is busy and doing
all these things and what Christ says is
the contemplative life is the better
portion not to say that we shouldn't
feed ourselves and you know we're living
in time and space we have to do certain
things to maintain our bodies but that
contemplation interpretation is actually
better than the act of life and uh we
obviously need both of these things but
we need if we're going to use our will
it has to be in accord with intellect
otherwise we're just going to start
throwing explosives at the wall you can
look at the way I wrote those letters to
determine what numbers they are it
96 B so what what I did was I flipped it
upside down and then I wrote a nine and
a six nines are not nines and six are
not drawn the same way the the when when
a person is taught to write they don't
draw nine by starting from the bottom
and then looping up around the top and
then go I mean you're making a lot of
points based on like modern culture and
all that let me just say this I think
the point the danger in all of this is
what I'm saying is if you become
steadfast on what you think it is and
there is no other like I'm not that much
modernist right okay but when you claim
something is what you think it is it
doesn't mean that it necessarily is to
other people that way then that's okay
all right you being that steadfast when
you say it is both a six and a nine
you're insisting upon that I'm trying to
be open-minded about it can be more than
one tyrannically open okay so here's the
not open-minded to my open-minded here
and and that's why I hate the phrase
open-minded it's meaningless yeah you
have to stop somewhere the point is Ian
the right tends to have a view of there
is meaning let me figure out what it is
and if it turns out the symbol never had
the ascribed meaning then it's not a six
or a nine it was a shape I just want to
make sure people don't live their life
based on what they thought that symbol
was and just go all the way without
considering that they might be wrong
right and that's what the left does and
when you offend their ego they insist
they were right oh it's a big problem
it's a big problem among all sides and
groups of people that I can see but the
problem is if you have two open of a
mind then you become a post-modernist
where it could be anything what if it
was just a sideways shape it wasn't even
a number right like so you had to Define
reality yeah all right we gotta go to
super chats everybody so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member so you can watch the uncensored
members only show which will be live at
about 10 10 p.m eastern time on the
front page of timcast.com and sign up at
the 25 level you can submit questions
and maybe even be a caller to the show
we typically are taking callers like now
so if you're in the Discord server now's
when you want to be submitting questions
to to get on the show or you can be a
member for at least six months at the 10
level
well let's read your super chats
all right I'm not your buddy guy says
how can we not worry about the people
who think humans are a blight on the
Earth are also the ones designing AI it
already thinks the right is evil yeah
it's we we're talking to me that they're
not open sourcing that thing right now
well we mentioned this uh before the
show Hank Green did a poll and he said
which universe is a better one with
humans without and 42 said without
humans
you first guys 30 of them were Bots I
hope they were yeah the robots being
like we don't like did you see chaos gbt
no so chaos GPT is the AI designed to
destroy humanity and what it first tried
to do was look up ways to get nuclear
weapons that didn't get them very far
that didn't get the bot very far and so
then the bot decided that the better way
to destroy Humanity was to manipulate
human beings and specifically to
manipulate human emotions and
specifically to do it by being a reply
guy in social media platforms no way
yeah and to but it couldn't go too far
it couldn't be too on the nose because
then the humans would get wise to it and
shut down the chaos gbt and it occurred
to me I know we've been talking about
demons a lot on the show tonight
that's just what the demons do right
they just kind of manipulate you and
tempt you but they try not to go too far
and it's just everything what people
thought two thousand years ago even more
than two thousand years ago it was just
all right it was all right and we think
we're such Geniuses because we talk
about it now with computers but nothing
has changed it's all exactly the same
I think we're psychic but it's been
dampened I they used to probably be more
psychic and they could sense God maybe I
think uh some people have stronger
connections than others I think that uh
call it whatever you want third eye
um spiritual connections whatever some
people have strong connections and their
whole life they just know there's God
they can feel the presence and they're
confused as to why you don't and then
there's some people who are completely
closed off and think they're a moist
robot and you're insane for thinking
otherwise I used to be like that and
then I learned God I think it was when I
humiliated myself in public on the
internet I I started making internet
videos and just telling all my I kept
people that like thoughts will come to
your brand you guys ever have that where
you're just sitting there you're like oh
these crazy stuff I just told the world
what my thoughts were and they stopped
popping into my head I was like oh then
I started hearing God I was like okay
this is real like that is a real thing
let's read this well we got a good one
Goldilocks production says Nebraska
became the 27th state to pass
constitutional carry today it passed
Congress and now just has to be signed
by the governor who will sign it
immediately let's go Brandon 27 States
think about how fast it's been
accelerated yes that's really big man I
mean and if you look at gun rights in
the 80s
gun rights used to not be a thing yeah
like most States would not give you
permits for Kerry there's two issues
that the right has one on there's only
two we've lost everything but the two
things we want on guns and pro-life
because it's the only issues where we
speak with moral Clarity we say no this
is a right you have a right to life you
have a right to protect yourself
we undid Roe v way that was pretty that
the fair point but then you got Colorado
that went the other direction so it's
kind of like rubber banding yeah no I
mean it's it's not going to be a
straight shot toward ending abortion but
just just overturning Roe v Wade we'll
save hundreds of thousands of babies a
year it's pretty good Tyler Pittman says
Jared from guns and gadgets is currently
streaming the Judiciary hearing he
expressed that he's interested in being
on timcast but doesn't know how to
contact you guys I'm just a broke bro
trying to spread the word
um
and I don't know how he can tweet it
tweeted us I don't know yeah he can send
in his own Super Chat why is he got to
rely on a broke Pro to send in the suit
yeah uh I don't know
all right where are we at spark says GOP
will lose in 2024. I live in Brooklyn
New York Democrat campaign staff came to
my house come to my house every day at 6
PM asking to vote Democrat in 2024 the
GOP is asleep at the wheel again
I hope the Democrats are focusing all of
their attention on convincing New
Yorkers to vote Democrat in presidential
elections but in all the California and
New York and we'll go to the swing
States yeah Mark D says I was retweeted
by Jeremy boring tonight mention it on
timcast and make this Marine Corps
Veteran Day even better congratulations
and thanks for your service that's great
and uh I'm really excited we ordered I
think 2 000 of the the daily wise
chocolate bars but it was it's an
important business purchase um we have
snacks we have granola bars we have
drinks you have great snacks we have we
got the keto granola bars and now we're
going to have Jeremy's uh she her
nutless bars and I just ordered I think
600 cans of conservative dad's Ultra
ripe beer
we're gonna get so fat yeah don't look
at me I mean you you can eat all the
chocolate you want that's one of the
things that the challenges of working at
timcast is control your gluttony yeah
because we make sure you know we're
Communists here so everybody has
whatever they want and there's food and
pizza we I ordered Starbucks the past
three days in a row for everybody I know
I'm not a bit like once we get Casper
coffee up and running we're gonna have
and there's no more Starbucks I will say
this is how I knew that your show was
really doing great is every time I would
come in the bar would get in like not
infinitely but exponentially more
ridiculous that's the that's like the
craziest bar I've ever seen the drinks
over there yeah I mean the Pappy's gone
the Pappy's the people there's a Louis
XII up there you got the Louis XII you
got the Laphroaig 25 it's unbelievable
gold over there for a while you ever
drink that uh we got Manuka honey
there's there's Manuka Honey wow yeah
that's expensive Australian import uh we
cracked open the Louis XII when Elon
took control of Twitter that's a good
occasion we're like we need a reason to
like this is a very expensive bottle of
cognac now but but none of us really
drink it's mostly just because uh we we
have prominent worldly people who come
on this show and uh you know we treat
them like kings I don't drink any booze
that's true but you do have prominent
worldly lushes who come on this show um
I mean look you know you can't wait when
we have when we have prominent
individuals of Merit we want to make
sure we're treating them with the utmost
respect yeah and so we we had corn
whiskey up there for a while cost five
bucks because some people prefer the
down to earth you know local Joe brand
but I'm really excited for the beer that
we get we normally like to buy local and
uh Ultra right conservative conservative
dad's Ultra right American Beer we'll
have that for our guests and for our
events and stuff like that did Seth
weather start Ultra what is it Ultra
right conservative dad is that what it's
called the club I believe it was him
yeah he's under super chat we'll read it
in a minute in a minute let's uh let's
read this what do we got Douglas Kaplan
says Michael Knowles best from The Wire
LOL said I missed your show question for
Michael have you heard of Frank Turek I
think you and him can even interesting
conversation he is from a channel called
cross-examine and may maybe bring hope
and understanding to Faith In Jesus Oh I
like the name sounds Vaguely Familiar
but I'm not really familiar with his
work so I gotta I gotta check him out
oh snap it's Dave says hey Tim I know I
know a long way from this but look into
Baldwinsville New York a left of center
Town very Pro small business we have an
old Pizza Hut for sale perfect for
coffee shop outside my BJJ gym
in um Frederick there's a Pizza Hut for
sale and I really want to go into
business with Jack pesobic and launch
Papa Jack's piece of Shack
and bring back that little store Pizza
Hut oh stained glass kind of lamps salad
bar I was explaining this to my wife
sweet little Lily so the other day
because she grew up she was a little
fancy you know she didn't go to the
Pizza Huts and I said I said you know
you don't know what you were missing
this was very high class dining take and
think about what they've taken from us
that crispy crust oh yeah those red cups
with the crystalline oh that was scary
that salad bar just coated in disease
yeah Gabby Hayes says Tim I know you
can't show the memes right now from
Chris Tyson's old posts but you should
on tonight's uncensored show for a few
minutes I want to see Michael's reaction
Ian too love you all uh okay are you
familiar with Chris Tyson so he's the Mr
Beast guy who decided he was a woman
he's got a bunch of old spicy memes that
I can't say on YouTube I know he he
posted about it and and I'll tell you
this I no one here even wanted to read
what he posted on the uncensored show
because nobody wants those words it's
kind of like when Obama read his Auto
biographies like sometimes we ate dog
and we did a lot of cocaine but I
imagine Chris Dyson's is way worse I do
know they're they're like they're funny
memes they were just boilerplate 4chan
edges but right right wasn't he invoice
I mean he's obviously into weird porn
stuff but it wasn't there like weird
like that that might have just been
shock edgy Edge Lord stuff right you
just don't know my take on that was not
that he's there for a pedo or something
like that maybe his maybe isn't but I I
didn't conclude that he was my take on
that though was this guy is fluent in
the language of pornography if he's
using really obscure terms that you've
got to Google or probably you shouldn't
Google then he probably knows you think
it's 4chan well we'll show you the memes
of the uncensored show and then you know
but it's more of a meme than anything
[Music]
um
all right here we go
because of the Moon says hello Mr
Knowles would America and the world be
objectively better if its government was
a Christian Catholic theocracy well
every government is a kind of a
theocracy in the sense that all human
conflict is is ultimately theological
and the law just expresses and enforces
an understanding of justice so there is
no such thing as a total separation of
religious thinking and state that has
never existed anywhere so what you're
asking me is should we live under a
state animated by Christianity which is
animated our whole civilization for as
long as we've been a thriving one or
should we have a state animated by I
don't know leftism nihilism sadism and I
think if I got those options
Christianity sounds pretty good I'd like
to answer this um the statement
objectively better is not objective what
what does better mean different people
like different things if you're talking
about from our perspective on what good
things are I'll put it this way clearly
the left doesn't it would not be better
for leftists who like destroy things and
don't want you to have civil rights well
they wouldn't think it was better for
them but it certainly would be better
right if if they lived in a country
where they were encouraged to just be
normal and have a good life instead of
just chopping themselves up let's define
better then better being you will have a
higher standard of living you will be
safer and you will be happier and be
happier then I I believe the answer is
is not definitively yes but slightly
leaning in that direction yeah and
because because a government is no
guarantee on the actual values being
instilled so what we should say is
would the world be better if all people
were Christian or Catholic and the
answer is objectively yes and I'm not
saying that Christianity is 100 correct
although I think you probably would
agree I would say it is my point is
simply if everyone shares a cohesive
culture and agrees upon what the rules
are you would not need government you
would not need police people would have
a shared faith and moral system where
they would work with each other but
people would still be fallen people
would still sin right like you you
wouldn't need nearly the police presence
or government imposition you'd still
need people you know but it would be
you're right it would be much more
cohesive and it would just be in
accordance with
truth you know I mean I'm not saying
that I've got perfect knowledge of every
aspect of society and human life but I
can know it is better to I actually
brought this this example up on this
show before I can at least know it's
better to bake a pie for a widow than to
kick a baby right and so if we had a
society that would Shrine that in the
law
yeah be a better Society I think
centering society around God would be a
good move but I have seen people use
that for their power and benefit
throughout history and that's the
government component not the god
components but also the the law is a
teacher so you know it it's true that
culture affects the law but the the law
will also inform the culture and even
you know one once laws are passed they
can be in the news and we can all be
arguing over oh Roe v Wade got
overturned or whatever but then people
don't think consciously about the law
the law is just the heir the law is just
the water that the fish are swimming
through and that does influence our
Behavior because of incentives when you
incentivize something you get more of it
when you disincentivize something you
get less of it Amish man says Ian said
that he believes in God argument over if
you believe in God then you accept
miracles happen the creation of man out
of nothing is a miracle yeah well I
don't think matter created out of
nothing it's like hydrogen at first it's
plasma then it cools down and becomes
hydrogen and then is fused into here
where did the energy come from I don't I
don't think I think it's always been
here
so God didn't create so you so you're
saying you don't believe in God I think
it's just always been here
so God did did not create the created
World well things got fused together to
create what we know as matter but uh
we're the things
it didn't have to have come from like I
don't think maybe
my response to all of this is like there
exists things be outside of human
comprehension Infinity yeah it can be
real so my my issue with it is
um we'll read
I I guess that's what I was trying to
explain I you know yeah that we we can't
necessarily comprehend creation of
matter we are we are we are within the
confines of the system so we don't know
it exists Beyond it and if we are to
relate it to anything in our world
looking at say computer programs
Mario has no intelligence compared to a
human we have no intelligence compared
to God also if you're saying you believe
in God but you also think that this
created world has just always been here
which I understand is a contradiction
are you are you saying that the universe
is older than God I think time is not
real well
sorry I I don't think it's a
contradiction we'll just say to say the
created world has always been here means
I I I would argue that time is a
component of the of of this re this
universe created by God and that there
perhaps is something well beyond it that
we can't conceive of
sure it's obviously if if the universe
is finite in space-time or part of the
created world then obviously there's
something outside of that I'm just
saying right you can't you can't say
it's both created and not created right
think of it this way uh imagine however
you want God or an entity or whatever
and there is it creating the universe
however you imagine what that is time is
a component of this reality that we
don't necessarily perceive we move
through in One Direction as though we're
falling so if you imagine time as a
dimension it would be like we are just
Free Falling we can't go back in the
other direction but the direction does
exist and if it's possible that time is
actually
um
um cyclical that uh the that time is not
moving from from point A to point B in
fact it goes in a big circle and Loops
back around then it would pers it would
be perceived to us as always having been
because time is well that that's yeah
that's something more into what the
Hindus or the Buddhists would believe
but God could still have created it
because time is not the not the
Christian the Christian God would would
uh but that would imply that God is
confined to time and I don't believe
that no no God is outside of time and
space and though he through the
Incarnation takes part in time and space
but I'm just saying that the the notion
the Christian notion is that history has
a beginning and history has an end and
history has this pivotal point which is
the Incarnation and the crucifixion of
the Resurrection but but the idea that
there is such a thing as history at all
no no we're moving that's that's
absolutely true
but then it wouldn't be cyclical if
we're if we're talking about the
universe and all that it's matter is a
is is in a Time Loop but there is a
point that is a beginning and end of
History I think can exist as well I I so
so it's kind of like a loop-de-loop
sometimes it's not a it's not a circle
it's just kind of going that isn't doing
it it's moving in multiple Dimensions
going it's certainly but it's also going
forward so it's spiraling but I'm just
saying even if it's kind of goes on a
loop-de-loop if it starts one place and
ends in another place then it's linear
right even if it's um well it's moving
in every direction at once
well then no no interesting thoughts I'd
have to think about it yeah but let's
read some more Super chats I I do like
that though it makes makes me think
all right let's uh what do we got here
we'll grab some oh I like the simulation
Theory stuff
let's see man uh Mandalore the mighty
says simulation theory is God using Star
Trek technobabble both are technically
correct the best type of correct
Futurama joke
I think of God as like the the movement
of matter the formation and creation and
just animation of all things is God it's
that's that is not what God is it's the
way it's the way things are moving and
then I was like God is the way and then
I was like no that actually says that in
the Bible
it's not a thing it's the way but that's
like saying in GTA the computer code is
the creator of the video game right now
a human being programmed that video game
I don't there is no I don't think this
isn't a video game this has just always
been here this thing yeah it's just
we're just part of it well the thing the
thing you're describing then is not uh
God that the being that you're
describing is not God you're you're just
describing a kind of a nature worship
you're describing a kind of a paganism
which which a lot of the new age
movements partake of but but you're
saying that God is just kind of
synonymous with nature or with different
parts of nature but that's that's a very
different idea
it's a truth and the light and I thought
truth is the way the life the truth is
the way you communicate the life is the
way that you grow I mean it's all just
part of the way things move let's read
some more Super chats because otherwise
we're just talking in circles Noah
Sanders says my dad and I have been
making seltzers with fresh fruit and
other ingredients is there any advice
y'all could give for starting up our own
company to combat these ones that
despise us we'd love to work with y'all
one day oh that sounds fantastic uh
what's what how do we find the website
you should have put the name in the
Super Chat let me know he should have
put it in it's all I drink I drink black
coffee I drink booze and I drink fruit
very rarely in a pinch otherwise I am
I'm gonna go bankrupt on Spindrift so if
you give me a cheaper alternative I'm
I'm there yeah it'd be great Seth
weather is Senate big old Super Chat he
says conservative dad's Ultra right beer
loves Tim cast Knowles is okay Knowles
is okay
he could tell I'm not a Beer Drinker
that's why I was fine when Bud Light
went gay or trans I guess because my
preferred canned alcohol is white claw
which is already so gay that they're
never going to have to sponsor a
transvestite that's not even it's
already there I just don't drink alcohol
I I don't know yeah I I had an apple
cider this past weekend because I'm not
like oh I will never drink it's usually
just like I just it doesn't taste good
oh hard cider yeah like I'll go out with
people and they'll order beers and I'll
be like ah what the heck I'll get one
I'll take one stepping back I'm done
yeah
it is weird that a lot of very
successful High performing people don't
drink you don't drink Trump doesn't
drink I don't I want Charlie Kirk I've I
don't know that I've ever seen him drink
I think
I mean I I take uh Health moderate I
would say moderate to moderately to
highly seriously if I I wouldn't say
extremely because then I'd be lifting
but uh exercise I cut the sugars down
way way down and I don't drink alcohol I
don't smoke also no tattoos you know you
wanna know something really crazy to me
that I've I've absolutely retained since
I was a kid like the Bible prohibition
on tattoos and piercings when I when I
learned that when I was a kid
I don't consider myself to be deeply
religious but I really just have an
aversion to body modifications
sorry to interrupt but why why is that
in the Bible why no tattoos no no
piercings I kind of just feel like it's
like
your body man it's it's it's what was
it's a beautiful snowflake is it like an
anti-pagan thing it's not I mean it's
it's not an aspect of the unchanging
moral law in the sense that it's it's
more ceremonial and related to the
nation of Israel but I I so I'll I'll
eat shellfish and I'll eat pork but uh
yeah I'm not into tattoos or body
modification it doesn't do it for me I
kind of just look at it like uh when
when uh raindrop is crystallizing and
becomes a unique structure humans are
the same way the energy comes together
and forms something that is deeply
unique and then humans don't feel unique
enough and then want to get tattoos and
stuff and I don't care if other people
do it I'm not gonna I'm not judging them
I'm just saying for me I'm kind of like
it also I don't want you know if a
marine gets a tattoo or a some kind of
Sailor gets a tattoo or a convict or
something that seems right I don't know
there seems something fitting about that
but what drives me crazy when pretty
girls get the tattoos I I'm not saying
they can never look good I'm not saying
I'm total but I think these pretty why
why I have a controversial taken it's
that no attractive woman look looks more
attractive after getting a tattoo she'll
still be attractive but only in spite of
her tattoo yes yeah it never it's at the
very best neutral which is rare and
right but it never yeah let's uh one one
more Super Chat James hates everything
says Ian's nonsense tonight left me
speechless just like the best-selling
book by Michael Knowles my man here we
go where do people get like two years on
I know get it wherever you buy fine
number one best-selling turning your ad
into a meme that is unbelievable that
wow great talk this is that you know
it's the thing where jokes can start off
kind of funny and then they get really
lame and then they just get like very
very funny again every every time the
joke is told Michael Knowles bank
account goes up yeah it literally that
certainly makes me it makes me smile all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
the uncensored members only show up in
about 10 minutes you're not going to
want to miss it and of course remember
members who are there for at least six
months or the 25 level we will be taking
your calls tonight answering your
questions in real time so smash that
like button you can follow the show at
timcast IRL on Instagram and Facebook
you can follow me personally at timcast
Michael do you want to shout anything
out uh yeah I do I want to shout out a
lot of stuff uh obviously we've got our
chocolate bars here for daily wire she
her and he him and then you guys try it
I'm kind of down on sugar though not
really a food ASMR person I just tried I
did ASMR for the first time oh it's it's
unbearable yeah see I hate it make me
angry so I well actually this is the
thing I'll shout out on my YouTube
channel Michael Knowles show you can
subscribe we've been doing these extra
releases in addition to my show these
really long interviews Michael and we
did it within a one with an exorcist one
with a kind of druggie who turned his
life around but then we do these these
breakouts of just kind of weird things
that my producer Ben Davies wants to
introduce me to and he made me do like a
woman just chomping on a honeycomb and I
figured I think it was kind of gross but
who cares I thought you meant you were
gonna make the ASMR I'm yeah I'm gonna
start in only fans yeah I'm that's the
other thing I'm shutting on no I'm not
not doing any of those things someone's
buying nudes from people who hate you
buy them from Michael instead
he's just kidding do you have more to
shout out I do yeah let's see I already
did ASMR I'm gonna start doing a mukbang
company do you ever hear about that
that's the other kind of that uh no but
I actually would say if people want to
head over to my YouTube channel Michael
Knowles show we're starting to Branch
out into the yes or no game into face
off into these long interviews so check
that out now the one with the Exorcist
when went viral in a short period of
time got well over 2 million views uh so
if you if you want more than just the
daily podcast we play this game for the
uncensored show we should play the yes
or no I wanted to make that I yes we
have this game yes or no game it's sold
out I think we got more in though so you
can order it at dailywire.com shop it is
the it is the number one board game on
the internet at least I'm saying that
and and uh you can get it you can watch
the episodes on my show you can play it
yourself and hey who knows maybe we'll
play it over here yeah in the uncensored
show we'll bring it up I want to show
you those memes that everyone wants you
to see and have you react to so we'll do
that uh yeah you gotta you shout out
everything should we move on or let's
see I got like 10 other things I've got
no I'm joking all right Mary
okay go subscribe to pop culture crisis
it's a show here at timcast where we
talk about celebrities movies
entertainment and all of that good stuff
if you send super Chats on the show then
we get shot with money guns
um it's it's a fun time not as political
as Tim cast IRL and if you want to
follow me on Twitter or Instagram
they're both Mary archived I'm going to
be on pop culture crisis next Monday
yeah excited for that three to five PM
Eastern Standard Time pop culture crisis
on YouTube I'm also going to be in
Austin April 29th I will be uh with the
mises caucus for the take Human Action
tour and let's take human actiontour.com
for tickets Austin Texas uh I think all
the locations and everything is there so
hopefully I'll see you out there and
then we'll maybe chat after the show
looking forward to that thanks great
conversation tonight guys that was
really this is this is this game's gonna
be fun all right I'm already looking for
a question take it away yeah I am
search.com I'm excited Michael free to
see 4chan memes oh yeah I can't wait
okay that's gonna be good uh yeah good
show I enjoyed uh the camera work for
this it was quite fun uh yeah all right
all right everybody we will see you at
timcast.com in a few minutes thanks for
hanging out